بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد وزير
رئيس مجلس الوزراء في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو اصحاب
المعالي والسعاده السيدات والساده السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
لقد شرفني سياده رئيس الجمهوريه السيد عبد
المجيد تبون رئيس القمه العربيه بالقائك
كلمته الرئاسيه بمناسبه افتتاح الدوره
الثانيه والثلاثين لمجلس جامعه الدول
العربيه على مستوى القمه هذا نصها
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسوله الكريم صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
السيده الامينه العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه
السيد رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
السيد الامين العام لمنظمه التعاون
الاسلامي السيدات والساده
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
اود في مستهل كلمه ان اتقدم بجزير الشكر
وعظيم الامتنان لصاحب الجلاله خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود ولصاحب السمو الملكي ولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز
رئيس مجلس الوزراء على كرم الضيافه وحفاوه
الاستقبال
لقد تشرفت الجزائر باحتضان الدوره الواحده
والثلاثين للقمه العربيه في ظروف اقليميه
ودوليه بالغه التعقيد فضلا عن اندلاع
الازمه الاوكرانيه التي وضعت العالم في
حاله استقطاب متزايد وامام تحديات جديده
متمثله خاصه في الامن الغذائي والطاقوي
وفي هذا الصدد اجدد الدعوه لتعبئه الطاقات
التمويليه العربيه لا سيما صندوق النقد
العربي والصناديق العربيه القائمه لمساعده
الدول الاعضاء التي هي في امس الحاجه لهذه
المساعدات لتمكينها من تجاوز هذه الظروف
الدوليه العصيبه
على الصعيد العربي ستنظم الجزائر خلال
الشهر الجاري الندوه العلمي الاولى حول
الامن الغذائي في الوطن العربي بحضور كبار
الخبراء والمختصين العرب للخروج بمقترحات
علميه وعمليه ومشاريع ملموسه تمهيدا
لاعتمادها وتجسيدها بما يدعم الامن
الغذائي لشعوبنا اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسمو لقد وضعت الجزائر رئاسه اهل القمه
العربيه تحت شعار لم الشمل حيث بعد اعاده
توحيد الصف الفلسطيني في الجزائر الذي كلل
بتوقيع الاشقاء الفلسطينيين على اعلان
الجزائر والتزامهم
بالعمل على تجسيد الاستحقاقات المتضمنه
فيه نواصل التنسيق مع اخي فخامه الرئيس
محمود عباس
مساعينا راميه لاستكمال مسار المصارحه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه شعار لم الشمل تجسد
كذلك باستعاده سوريا الشقيقه مقعدها
الطبيعي في جامعه الدول العربيه بفضل
الجهود ادؤوب التي بذلت ومما يضفي عن هذه
العوده طابعا خاصا بالنسبه للشعب الجزائري
كونها تاتي تزامنا مع احياء الجزائر لذكرى
مجازر 8 ماي 45 واود ان ارحب عاليا
باسترجاع سوريا لمقعدها بين اشقائها مع
توجيه الشكر الى كل الدول العربيه الشقيقه
التي ساندت مسعى الجزائر وعلى راسها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسمو وفاء
لمسؤولياتنا التاريخيه اذا الشعب
الفلسطيني الشقيق وتجسيدا لمركزيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه في وجدان الشعب الجزائري فلقد
سخرت الجزائر
دبلوماسيتها خدمه لقضيتنا المركزيه حيث
وصلنا المساعي على مستوى الامم المتحده
لحشد الدعم اللازم بغيه توسيع قاعده
الاعترافات الدوليه بدوله فلسطين
وحصولها على العضويه الكامله في منظمه
الامم المتحده وذلك بالتنسيق مع كافه
الاشقاء العرب كذلك
وبمناسبه الاحتفال باليوم العالم للتضامن
مع الشعب الفلسطيني طالبنا المجتمع الدولي
بتحمل مسؤولياته التاريخيه والسياسيه
والقانونيه والاخلاقيه والانسانيه تجاه
الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق ليس فقط لوضع حد
لتعنت الاحتلال ورفضه الال الشرعيه
والقرارات الدوليه وانما لاتخاذ الاجراءات
الكفيله بوضع حد لسياسه الاستيطان التي
تمارسها سلطه الاحتلال كما ساهمت الجزائر
في الخطوات العمليه التي تم اتخاذها من
اجل اعتماد قرار الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده للتفعيل دور محكمه العدل الدوليه
من اجل تكريس حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني فضلا
عن توقيعها للائحه التي تمت المصادقه
عليها من قبل الجمعيه العامه المتحده حيال
قرار السلطه الاحتلال بفرض اجراءات عقابيه
على الشعب الفلسطيني وقيادته ومجتمعه
المدني وهذا بعد طلب الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده لرايين استشاري من محكمه العدل
الدوليه مع رفض الجزائر كل الاجراءات
العقابيه داعيه رفقه باقي الموقعين الغاء
الفوري لهذه الاجراءات
من جانب اخر وتنفيذا لقرارات قمه الجزائر
ان عقد مؤتمر دعم القدس وتوج باعتماد جمله
من الاجراءات من شانها تعزيز صمود اهلنا
في القدس الشريف الذين يتعرضون يوميا الى
ممارسات اجراميه واستهداف حياتهم بالاضافه
الى القمع الاستيطاني الممنهج وسط صمت
دولي رهيب وعجز تام عن ضمان الحمايه
الدوليه للازمه للشعب الفلسطيني ومقدسته
لقد اقدمت سلطه الاحتلال على تصعيد خطير
تمثل في الغارات الجويه الغاشمه التي
شلتها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزه مخلفه العديد من الشهداء والجرحى من
بينهم اطفال ونساء عزا اننا ندين بشده هذه
الاعمال الاجراميه ونجدد تضامننا الكامل
والدائم مع الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق وندعو
المجتمع الدولي وخاصه مجلس الامن الدولي
لوقف هذه الاعتداءات الاجراميه المتكرره
والممنهجه وضمان الحمايه الدوليه للشعب
الفلسطيني وتمكينه من استرجاع حقوقه
المشروعه وعلى راسها اقامه دولته المستقله
وعاصمتها القدس الشريف وفقا لمبادره
السلام العربيه التي اكدنا جميعا تمسكنا
بها في قمه الجزائر
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسموم لطالما دعت
الجزائر لاسيما خلال القمه العربيه
السابقه الى الاهتداء بفضائل الحوار
لتاسيس علاقات بناء مع دول الجوار الجيو
السياسي التي نتقاسم معها روابط الدين
والتاريخ والارث الحضاري فضلا عن العامل
الجغرافي وفي هذا الاطار نعرب عن ارتياحنا
لبوادر الانفراج التي حدثت من خلال
التقارب الحاصل في العلاقات العربيه مع
الجارتين التركيه وايران والذين توسم فيه
انفراجا في ازمات المنطقه واستقرارها وخفض
التوترات مما يفتح افاقا رحب للتعاون
والشراكه ويمهد لاحلال السلام في المنطقه
وفي بعض الدول الاعضاء لا سيما في اليمن
الشقيق حيث نسمن كل الجهود المبذوله
لتسويه هذه الازمه بصفه نهائيه ورفع
المعاناه عن الشعب اليمني الشقيق كما نؤكد
على ضروره ضروره تعزيز التضامن مع اشقائنا
في الصومال وجيبوتي في مواجهه الجفاف الذي
تشهده منطقه القرن الافريقي للعام السادس
على التوالي والتي تتطلب منا تدخلا عاجلا
لتفادي كارثه انسانيه محدقه بهذين الشعبين
الشقيقين وكافه الشعوب بالمنطقه
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسمو يشهد
السودان الشقيق انفجار دائره العنف
والاقتتال بين ابناء الشعب الواحد بعد ان
استبشرنا بالاتفاق الاطار الذي تم التوقيع
عليه لطي صفحه مرحله الانتقاليه وثوره
تدهور التدهور المتسارع للاوضاع على خلفيه
استمرار المواجهات المسلحه بين الاشقاء
السودانيين سارعت الجزائر بارسال رسائل
الى كل من الامين العام المتحده والرئيس
الحالي للاتحاد الافريقي رئيس جمهوريه
القمر المتحده والامينه التنفيذي للهيئه
الحكوميه للتنميه ايجاد من اجل تحرك سريع
لحقن الدماغ والعوده الى المسار السلمي
لحل الازمه السودانيه العميقه بعيدا عن اي
تدخل خارجي في الشؤون الداخليه السودانيه
وندعم مجددا للاخوه الاشقاء في السودان
الى تغريب المصلحه العليا للوطن والاحتكام
الى فضائل الحوار لحل الخلافات وتجنيب
الشعب السوداني الشقيق مخاطر الانزلاق في
دوامه العنف الدموي الذي يشكل خطرا على
السلم الاجتماعي ووحده بلاد
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم لا يمكن
الحديث عن الاوضاع السائده في منطقتنا
العربيه بمعزل ما عما يشهده العالم من
تحولات عميقه وتطورات متسارعه تؤشر لظهور
نظام دولي جديد متعدد الاقطاب على انقاض
نظام نظام القطب الواحد ان هذا الوضع
بتعقيداته المتعدده
وبتداعياته الكبيره يفرض علينا تعزيز
التضامن والعمل كمجموعه موحده تستنير
بمبدا وحده المصير ليكون لنا دور فعال
وفاعل في تحديد توازنات الجديده بالشكل
الذي يضمن الحفاظ على مصالحنا المشتركه
ولنا من القدرات والامكانيات ما يسمح لنا
بتبؤ مكانه مكانه مرموقه للمساهمه في رسم
معالم مستقبل افضل لشعوبنا
من هذا المنطلق وادراكا منا بحجم وطبيعه
التحديات الجسيمه التي تواجه الامه
العربيه وانطلاقا من ايماننا العميق
بفضائل واهميه العمل العربي المشتركه
المتجدد اود التاكيد مجددا على حتميه
اصلاح وعصرنه العمل العربي المشترك وفق
نهج جديد يتجاوز المقاربات التقليديه ليضع
في صلب اولوياته انشغلات وهموم المواطن
العربي واذ اعرب عن امتنان لدعمكم
المقترحات التي تقدمنا بها من اجل تفعيل
دور جامعه الدول العربيه في الوقايه من
النزاعات وحلها وتعزيز مكانه الشباب
والابتكار في العمل العربي المشترك اشدد
على ضروره التجاوز هذا الاستعصاء الاصلاحي
والاسراع في تفعيل هذه العمليه الاصلاحيه
المحوريه لتمكيننا من مواجهه التحديات
المطروحه حاليا على مستويين الاقليمي
والدولي
في الختام لا يسعني الا ان اتوجه بخالص
التهاني وعظيم التقدير
[موسيقى]
لاخي صاحب الجلاله خادم الحرمين الشريفين
وكذلك لصاحب السمو الملك الامير محمد بن
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه بمناسبه
التواليه رئاسه الدوره الثانيه والثلاثين
للقمه العربيه
سائدا المولى عز وجل ان يمده بعونه
وتوفيقه في تحمل هذه المسؤوليه الساميه
ونحن على ثقه تامه بان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه ستقود بكل جداره واقتدار
اشغال مجلسنا لمعاهدناه منها ومن قيادتها
الحكيمه من حرص دائم على وحده الصف العربي
وتفعيل وتطوير اليات العمل العربي المشترك
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
ونيابه عن رئيس القمه العربيه الواحده
والثلاثين سياده رئيس الجمهوريه السيد عبد
المجيد تبون يسعدني دعوه صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
الوزراء للمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
لتفضل بتسلم رئاسه القمه العربيه الثانيه
والثلاثين متمنيا له كل التوفيق والنجاح
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم وعلى بركه الله
افتتاح الدوره الثانيه والثلاثون لمجلس
جامعه الدول العربيه على مستوى القمه
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو الامين
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
الحضور الكرام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
يسرني ارحب بكم في بلدكم الثاني المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ونرحب بضيف القمه فخامه
الرئيسكي رئيس اوكرانيا ونامل ان تتكلم
جهودنا بالتوفيق والنجاح كما يسرني ان
اشكر فخامه الرئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه عبد المجيد تبون على
الجهود المبذوله خلال تراس بلاده للدوره
السابقه ونشكر معالي الامين العام لجامعه
الدول العربيه وجميع العاملين فيها على
مبادلوا من جهود لخدمه العمل العربي
المشترك
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم نؤكد لدول
الجوار والاصدقاء في الغرب والشرق للسلام
والخير والتعاون والبناء بما يحقق مصالح
شعوبنا ويصون حقوق امتنا واننا لن نسمح
ونتحول منطقتنا ميدان الصراعات ويكفينا طي
صفحه الماضي
تذكر سنوات مؤلمه من الصراعات عاشتها
المنطقه وعارت منها شعوبها وتعثرت بسببها
مسيره التنميه
اليوم حضور فخامه الرئيس بشار الاسد لهذه
القمه وصدور قرار جامعه الدول العربيه
بشان استئناف مشاركه وفود الحكومه السوريه
في اجتماعات مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه
ونامل ان يسهم ذلك في دعم استقرار سوريا
وعوده الامور لطبيعتها واستئناف دورها
الطبيعي في الوطن العربي وما يحقق الخير
لشعبها وما يدعم تطلعاتنا جميعا نحو
المستقبل افضل لمنطقتنا الحضور الكرام من
القضيه الفلسطينيه كانت ولا زالت هي قضيه
العرب والمسلمين المحوريه
وتاتي على راس اولويات السياسات المملكه
الخارجيه ولم تتوانى المملكه او تتاخر في
دعم الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق لاسترجاع
اراضيه واستعاده حقوقه مشروعه واقامه دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله ذات سياده على اراضي
الفلسطينيه بحدود عام 67 وعاصمتها القدس
الشرقيه
وفقا لقارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومبادره
السلام العربيه وغيرها من المرجعيات
الدوليه المتفق عليها بما يحقق مظلات
الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق
الناشقاق في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يكرسون جهودهم في دعم القضايا العربيه كما
نعمل على مساعده اطراف اليمنيه للوصول الى
حل سياسي شامل ينهي الازمه اليمنيه وفيما
يخص السودان نامل ان تكون لغه الحوار هي
الاساس للحفظ على وحده السودان وامن شعبه
مقدراته وفي هذا الصدد المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ترحب بتوقيع طرفي نزاع على اعلان
جده الالتزام بحمايه مدنيين وتسهيل العمل
الانساني ونامل التركيز خلال هذه
المحادثات على وقف فعال لاطلاق النار
تواصل مملكه بالتعاون مع الاشقاء
والاصدقاء والمجتمع الدولي
بذل الجهود الانسانيه وتفعيل قنوات
الاغاثه للشعب السوداني الشقيق ويطيب لنا
ان ننتهز هذه الفرصه بوجود فخامه الرئيس
ايلينسكي رئيس اوكرانيا ومشاركه هذه القمه
المجدد موقف المملكه الداعم لكل ما يسهم
في خفض حده الازمه في اوكرانيا وعدم تدهور
الاوضاع الانسانيه واستعاده المملكه
واستعداد المملكه الاستمرار في بدل الجهود
الوساطه بين روسيا الاتحاديه واوكرانيا
ودعم جميع الجهود الدوليه للراميه الى حل
الازمه سياسيا بما يرسم في تحقيق الامن
والسلم الحضور الكرام انه وطننا العربي
يملك من المقومات الحضريه والثقافيه
والموارد البشريه والطبيعيه ما يؤهل لتبني
مكانه متقدمه وقياديه وتحقيق نهضه شامله
لدولنا في جميع المجالات والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
والان ادعو معالي السيد احمد ابو الغيط
جامعه الدول العربيه لالقاء كلمته فليتفضل
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
السيدات والساده ابدا كلمتي بتقديم جزيل
الشكر والامتنان الى خادم الحرمين
الشريفين جلاله الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
ال سعود واليكم صاحب السمو الملكي ومن
خلالكم الى شعب المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الكريم على ما احطنا به من رعايه وحسن
وفاده منذ وصولنا الى هذه الارض المباركه
وان اهنئكم على تؤليكم رئاسه القمه في
دورتها الثانيه والثلاثين وادعو الله ان
يوفقكم الى ما فيه خير امتنا وشعبنا
ان المشهد الدولي يمر بواحده من اشد
الفترات خطوره في التاريخ المعاصر واراه
زمن استقطاب وتنافس هائل بين القوى الكبرى
على حساب القوى الاصغر او المنفرده ولذلك
فليس امام الدول العربيه في هذه المرحله
التاريخيه العصيبه سوى ان تستمسك بالمصالح
العربيه معيارا اساسيا للمواقف الدوليه
وان تلتزم بالتنسيق فيما بينها وبالعمل
الجماعي سبيلا اكيدا لتعزيز الكتله
العربيه في مواجهه ضغوط الاستقطاب
ان ازمات منطقتنا العربيه لم تجد للحل
طريقا بعد عقد واكثر من المعاناه والدماء
والالام فملايين العرب ما زالوا لاجئين
ونازحين واليوم اضيف اضيف الى احزان هذه
الامه حزن جديد في السودان يدفع المدنيون
ثمنا ضخما للمواجهه المسلحه التي فرضها
البعض على هذا البلد العزيز انا لتلك
المواجهات ان تتوقف وان تلتزم الاطراف
بمبدا الحوار صونا لدماء الشعب وحفاظا على
السودان ومقدراته ووحدته الترابيه وسلامه
مؤسساته الوطنيه
انني ادعو لان تكون قمه جده علامه بدء
لتفعيل حل عربي يوقف نزيف الدم في السودان
ويصحح اخطاء ارتكبت في الماضي وتوخى
المصلحه العليا للدوله السودانيه وليس
المصالح الضيقه لفئات او اشخاص
حقيقه سياده الرئيس اننا نسعى لايقاف نزيف
الدم والخسائر في كافه ميادين الاحتراب
الالي حيث لا منتصر ولا مهزوم والازمات
العربيه تشهد الان حاله من التجميد مقارنه
باوضاع اشد اشتعالا شاهدناها في السابق
خلال العقد الماضي وهي فرصه يتعين
اغتنامها من اجل تفعيل حلول العربيه لتلك
الازمات العربيه
ففي سوريا وارحب هنا بالرئيس بشار الاسد
بعد ان عادت سوريا الى مقعدها في هذا
المجلس الموقر ثمه فرصه لا ينبغي تفويتها
لمعالجه الازمه التي تعاني منها البلاد
لما يربو على العقد سواء في اسبابها
واصولها التي يظل الحل السياسي السبيل
الوحيد لتسويتها او في تبعاتها التي
تجاوزت حدود الوطن السوري
ويحضون الامل في ان يكون للعرب اسهامهم في
ايجاد الحلول الناجعه للاوجاع السوريه
العديده
السيد الرئيس لقد عانت المنطقه العربيه
زمنا ولا تزال من التدخلات الاقليميه في
شؤونها ولم تنتج هذه التدخلات تنتج هذه
التدخلات سوى حصاد من التمزق والفرقه
والدم واليوم تمت اشارات على ان نهج
الجيران يمكن ان يتغير انني ارحب مجددا
بالاتفاق الذي اوقع بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
في مارس الماضي فالعلاقات مع الجيران كافه
يجب ان تتاسس دوما على اساس من احترام
مبادئ حسن الجوار وعدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه للدول انها مبادئ اساسيه في
ميثاق الامم المتحده وهي مبادئ تتمسك بها
دولنا الوطنيه ولا تفرط فيها وتبقى فلسطين
الغاليه هما لا يحم لا يحمله اهلها وحدهم
لقد ادت الممارسات الرعناء لحكومه
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه الى تصعيد مروع في
منسوب العنف والقتل في الشهور الاخيره
انني احيي صمود الفلسطينيين في كل مكان في
الارض المحتله واقول ان السياسات
والممارسات الاستفزازيه لتلك الحكومه
الممعنه في التطرف والكراهيه لابد ان
تواجههم بتصدي حازم من مجتمع الدوليه عوضا
عما نشهده من صمت مريب ومشين سيد الرئيس
تم تحركه وحيويه في العمل العربي
والتجاهل واضح لاعاده امتلاج القضاء
امتلاك القضايا وتفعيل الادوار وان يتحول
العرب الى فاعلينا وليس مفعولا بهم واظن
ان هذه القمه في جده قمه التجديد والتغيير
تمثل خطوه مهمه طريق استعاده العرب لقضايا
وملفات طرقت للاخرين زمنا فتعقدت مساراتها
وتشبكت خيوطها اننا اليوم على عتبه طريق
صعب للانخراط الفاعل مع الازمات والسعي
لتسويتها وعلينا ان نسير فيه بكل العزم
والجهد حفاظا على امن الامه وشعوبها وصونا
لحاضرها ومستقبلها اتمنى لاعمال هذه القمه
كل النجاح والتوفيق شكرا سياده الرئيس
اشكر معالي السيد احمد ابو الغيط على
كلمته والان ادعو فخامه الرئيسسكي رئيس
اوكرانيا لالقاء كلمته فليتفضل
اشكركم على ضيفتكم الحر ونشكر صاحب السمو
الملكي والعهد محمد بن سلمان
للشعب السعودي هو مدينه جده التي تستضيف
هذه القمه
كلنا هنا من اجل السلام والعداله ايها
المشاركون الكرام
اليوم
هو اليوم 450 من الحرب الشامله التي ضدنا
من قبل الغازات الروس ليس لدينا صواريخها
كما يمتلكها العدو والقوه الجويه اضعف ولا
نمتلك
المسيرات القاتله العديده التي تسودها
ايران لروسيا
وليس لدينا الكثير من المدفعيه ولكننا
صامدون لان
الحق
الى جانبنا وعلاوه على ذلك فان نحن ندفع
المحتله خارج بلادنا كل من يدافع عن ارضه
في وجه الغزاه وكل من يدافع عن اطفال امته
من الاستعباد
كل محاربه ذلك يسير على طريق العداله وانا
فخور لان امثله حول المقاتلين الابطال
والشعب الاوكراني باكمله الاوكرانيون
لم يختارها الحرب ابدا جنودنا
لم يغزوا اراضي اخرى ونحن لا ننخرط في
عملياتي
او انتهاك لمصادر دول اخرى ولكننا لن نخضع
ابدا
لاي عدو او مستعمر ولهذا فنحن نقاتل وانا
متاكد ان كل دول تتفهم لذلك وانا متاكد من
اممكم
تتفهم كلمتي التي يودنا وهو نداء نبيله
لكم جميعا المساعده في حمايه شعبنا من
ضمنهم حتى الجاليه الاوكرانيه معي هنا
مصطفى جميل
قائد اهل الشعب من القرنه هو من السكان
الاصليين لاوكرانيا وطنهم
مركز الثقافه الاسلاميه في اوكرانيا
لقرون وترى اوكرانيين
جزء لا يتجزا من الجاليه المستوى
والمسلمين في العالم ولكن
الكرم تعاني من احتلال الروسي والى الان
فاغلب هؤلاء
الخاضعين القمع في القرن المحتله من
المسلمين
سبق وان عشنا تجربه ايجابيه مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
ثم يخصون اطلاق صلاحيه الاسرى الذين
اسرتهم روسيا او بامكاننا
او حتى وان كان هنالك في هذه القمه لديهم
وجهه نظر مختلفه حول الحرب على ارضنا
ويسمونها نزاعا فانا متاكد من اننا نستطيع
ان نتوحد من اجل انقاذ الاشخاص من اقفاص
السجون الروسيه
للاسف هنالك حول العالم ممن غض النظر عن
تلك الاقفاص وعمليات الضم غير القانونيه
وانا هنا
الجميع نظره صادقه على الامر مهما حاول
الروس التاثير يجب ان يكون هنالك استقلالا
ومن وجهه نظر اود ان اشكر المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واغلبتكم على دعمنا ودعم المواقف
الدوليه وميثاق الامم المتحده ايها
المشاركون الكرام
انتم تعرفون بين شعب اوكرانيا وشعبه سلام
في عام 2021
اولوياتنا كانت
مفتتحه لشعوبكم ولشعب الملكي العربي
السعودي
وعمان والبحرين والكويت
تعرفوا على اوكرانيا بشكل جيد وانا سعيد
للسياحه شاهدوا
جمال عاصمتنا كييف
وجبال كارتاتيا وانا اؤمن بان يوما ما
شعوبكم ستعود ايضا
لرؤيه القرن الاوكرانيه الحره من الاحتلال
الروسي
علاقاتنا ايضا متجذره
بتعليم عشرات الالاف من طلب العرب في
جامعاتنا في كل عام
يشرفنا ان الاطفال من المغرب ومصر والاردن
والعراق ولبنان والجزائر وليبيا وتونس
درسوا في اوكرانيا معكم نحن
نكمله واحده من اصعب واهم المحامي في
العالم الغذائي اوكرانيا على مر التاريخ
وتزودوا دوالكم بالقمح ومنتجات زراعيه
اخرى
ويسرنا ان نرحب باستثمارات في الدول
العربيه ايضا واستثمارات
قطر في البنى التحتيه
مع بعد الجائحه وحتى
الفيروس
اثر على كل هذه العلاقات وانا متاكد من ان
لا احد منكم
سيوافقوا على تسليم ولا
سم من اراضيكم وانا متاكد من لا احد منكم
اطفالكم الذين يتم ترحيلهم الى روسيا
ويفصلون عنها
وهم في روسيا يحاولون تعليم اطفالنا
كراهيه
اهاليهم وانا متاكد من ان لا احد منكم
الاحتلال العسكري لمحطه نوويه لاستخدامها
من اجل ابتزاز العالم بكارثه نوويه جديده
انظروا
تم من المعاناه اثرت الحروب على ليبيا
وسوريا وكم من الحيوانات زهقت بعد سنوات
من القتال في السودان والصومال والعراق
وافغانستان
كل من يزيد من المعاناه باعتداءاته
الجديده
كل من يحيى العداوه
ويريد ان يعيد
ايام الامبراطوريات الغازيه التي
تفرض ارادتها على الدول المستقله كل ما
تدي يواجه العالم وسوف يحكم عليه في
الختان وانا
احيي كل من قرر في مسار العداله اوكرانيا
اقترح حتى معادله السلام من اجل انهاء
الحرب ممتنكم ان تروا كيف انها تنطق على
الامن الغذائي واحده من نقاط معادلتنا حتى
عندما فرضت الحرب على اراضينا فنحن ندرك
نتاكد من صمود البقيه من خلال تزويدنا
للحبوب عبر مبادره البحر الاسود
يجب ان يرفع حصارهم البحريه على موالينا
احاديث تساعد في تحقيق الاستقرار لاسواقها
الغذاء وبسعه العديد من دول جامعه الدول
العربيه ان تطبيق نقطه اخرى معادله للسلام
[موسيقى]
الدول المستقله الامنه واوكرانيا اثبت
التدلك اتمنى لكم السلام
وادعوكم بالتعاون بشكل مباشر مع بلادنا من
دون اي وسطاء
واتمنى ان يعمل الجميع نحن واصدقائكم بعمل
او بشكل منسق من اجل مصحاته الشعوب كافه
الامم
وارجو ان تزوي الى الشعب
هي القرمه مسلمون
اوكرانيا واتمنى ان يحمل الله جل تعالى
جنودنا
الخليجي الساده
ادعوا معالي السيد
اخا ونصيرا للامه العربيه
وتضامنا معها في الظروف الدقيقه التي تمر
بها
يسعدني كذلك
ان اعرب عن جزيل الشكر
لخادم الحرمين الشريفين
احدى المفدى بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
خادم الحرمين
وكزا
فالكريم على الجلاله في هذا
الدولاب في الجامعه العربيه
معالي السيده الامينه العامه العربيه هذه
في ظرف بالق الدقه
اقليميه
السيده الامين
العام للمدمر
[موسيقى]
بل في مناطق شاسعه امامكم اليوم من العالم
ممثلا للاتحاد للنها
معه الامن
بها اما في ساحه العربيه
الحرمين الشريفين وتتضاع
الرقعه في الجامعه العربيه
للدعوه الاخويه واحتلال
المستوطنين
الحار
والضياف الكريمه التي حوزين بها في هذا
البلد العزيز
وارضه المقدسه
تنعقد قمتكم هذه في ظرف بالق الدقه
اقليميا وعالميا
فعلى صعيد الدولي
تستمر الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
المدمره للانسان والاقتصاديات العديده من
الدول ليس فقط في اوروبا بل في مناطق
شاسعه
من العالم
انها تهدد العالم
بشحه شديده في مصادر الطاقه
والقزاع والامن والاستقرار
اما في ساحه العربيه
فيتواصل العدوان الاسرائيلي على الشعب
الفلسطيني
وتتضاعف الاهانات ضده
وتتسع رقعه السلبه من اراضيه
واحتلال افواج المستوطنين قصرا وظلما
وعدوانا لمساحات حساسه منها كما يطول صمت
العالم المريب على هذه التراجديه المستمره
ضد الشعب الفلسطيني المحروم من حقه في
الحريه وتاسيس دولته المستقله ذات السياده
التامه
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه
وبمناسبه الذكرى الخامسه والسبعين لنكبه
المجتمه القوي فاننا الامراض بشده ذلك
العدوان المستمر ونطالب لجهود الدوليه
وربما اخيرا
خاصه
والمحافظه في هذه الاسماء لقد استمروا
انتقاليه
الى العنف لحل الخلافات بين الشركاء السي
والعسكريين ان الاتحاد الافريقي الذي كان
اول من دعا للثلاثيه الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد
ورتبها قد بادر منذ شراره الاولى للاقتتال
الراهن بالدعوه الى توحيد جهود المنظومه
الدوليه
اننا في الاتحاد الافريقي نرى ان بعثر
الجهود المنظومه الدوليه قد تكون من
مسببات اطاله الصراع كما علمتنا التجربه
في عديد من البلدان وفي هذا السياق رحبنا
بجهود المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه لحمل الطرفين
على وقف اطلاق النار وفتح الطريق امام
المساعدات الانسانيه لشعب السوداني
المنكوب اصحاب الجلال والصهي والمعالي
ايها الساده والسيدات اننا نؤمن بان
الصراع في السودان لن يكون له حل عسكري
نهائي وليس من مصلحه الشعب السوداني ولا
المنطقه ان يكون له حل عسكري ان الذين
تسولوا لهم انفسهم بذلك انما يعيشون على
الاوهام وهم مهما كانوا غير مبالين بما
يلحقه في العنف من دمار الدوله ومؤسسات
البلاد وبنيتها التحيه التحتيه وزحر وزحق
ارواح ابنائها
ان مغامره العنف تهدد تهديدا جديا المنطقه
كلها بالفوضى والحرب الاهليه والماسي بلا
نهايه اننا اننا ندعو الى تشكيل كتله
دوليه
تتبوا فيها الاتحاد الافريقي والجامعه
العربيه والامم المتحده والايجاد وغيرهم
من القوه الفاعله في الساحه السودانيه
كالرباعيه دورا رياضيا مركزيا وذلك من اجل
تعزيز الجهود الراميه الى السلام
واستئناف المسلسل السياسي لقيام حكومه
مدنيه تواجه التحديات العاجله وتعيد
المسار الانتقالي الى سكته تحضيرا
لانتخابات عامه حره ونزيهه اننا نهيب بهذه
القمه ان تتخذ في هذا التوجه قرارات حاسمه
قويه ونافسه لا شك ان قراراتكم في هذا
الشان وغيره من القضايا ذات الصله سيكون
له
الايجابي على ما ستدرسه وتغرر فيه القمه
العربيه الافريقيه التي ستنعقد هنا في هذا
البلد في هذه البلاد الطيبه بحر السنه
الجاريه اتمنى لقوتكم نجاحا باهرا سدد
الله اتقاكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته مازلنا نتابع مع حضراتكم كلمات
رؤساء الدول ورؤساء الوفود المشاركه في
القمه العربيه الثانيه 32 في جده وكانت
هذه كلمه رئيس المفوضيه الافريقيه
موسيفيكي والتي ركز فيها بشكل كبير على
ضروره ايجاد حلول عاجله وحاسمه لحل الازمه
في السودان تابعنا ايضا كلمه الرئيس
الاوكرانيه بلود ميرزنسكي والتي حملت
عنوان الرئيسيا لرساله مفادها ان اوكرانيا
لم تبدا الحرب ولكنها فرضت عليها
وانه هناك معاناه كبيره للشعب الاوكراني
هذه الكلمات
تاتي ضمن قمه يتم التعويل عليها كثيرا بان
تكون قمه
للمصالحه قمه لفتح افاق جديده للتعاون
والامل نستمع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
السلام عليكم ملك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
ورئيس الدوله الثانيه والثلاثين لمجلس
جامعه الدول العربيه اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسموم
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
ادرات السيدات والساده السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
يسعدني ان اتقدم الى خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود والى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بخالص التهاني الا رئاسه الدوره الثانيه
والثلاثين لمجلس جامعه الدول العربيه على
مستوى القمه
والسني وسني منها
بريد من من الفعاليات على العمل العربي
المشترك كما يسعدني ان يشيد برئاسه
الجمهوريه الجزائريه الشعبيه الديمقراطيه
التي في دوره السابقه وتقدم وتقدم لصاحب
السمو الامير فيصل بن فرحان ال سعود وزير
الخارجيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومعالي السيد احمد ابو الغيث الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه بخالص الشكر على
دعوته الكريمه لنا
الذي وجهها لنا للغدور لهذه القمه
واود ان اؤكد مجددا ولا عمق الروابط بين
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي وجامعه الدول
العربيه وعلى المبادئ والقيم
والقواسم المشتركه
ونتطلع الى زياده هذه العلاقات الى اسماء
درجات لما فيه مصالح
دولنا وتعقيق
بها في
السلام الامن والازدهار
قادمه الحرمين الشريفين اصحاب
الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو عضلات السيدات والساده
انتهز هذه الفرصه في طرق في ظرف دقيق
يواجه فيه
العالم العربي الاسلامي تحديات تنظر لنا
بتعزيز التعاون
والتضامن
والتكثيف الجهود والتنسيق
الشعب الفلسطيني وهي قديمه المركزيه
للعالم العربي والاسلامي
تشهد
استمرار غالبيه
حل السياسي واصطاد الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه
الغاشمه على الشعب الفلسطيني وعرضه
ومقدساته وخصوصا المسجد الاقصى المبارك
مما يهدد
بتعيين تعديد من
الشيعه تريد هذه تدهور الاوضاع والتطلبات
متطلبات ذلك توحيد مواقفنا وتعزيز جهادنا
على الساحه الدوليه لتوفير
الحمايه الدوليه للشعب الفلسطيني واقامه
دولتي هي المستقله على الهدود العام 1967
وعاصمتها القدس الشريف
تجد هذا القرار قرارات الشرعيه
اداه دوليه
والمبادرات
الدول الاسلاميه العربيه قضيه اخرى تثير
عميق
انشغالنا
وقلقنا وهي الازمه في السودان الشقيق فقد
دوانا في منظمه التعاون الاسلامي في منذ
اليوم الاول
لاندلاع الاشتباكات المسلحه الى الوقوف
العاجل والدائم لاطلاق النار
وللهوار
لعل
الخلافات وريانا بمبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه ورحبنا بالمبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه لبدء المحادثات الاوليه بين
ممثلين القوات المسلحه للسودانيه وممثلين
قوات الدعم السيء في مدينه جده كما رحبنه
بتوقيت على اعلان جده بشان الاعتزام
بحمايه المدنيين في السودان ونعمل ان يشكل
قطاعه او لا نحو انهاء النزاع المسله
بسوره نهائيه بما يعزز اسباب الامن
والسلام والاستقرار ومن هذا المنبر الموقر
الاشقاء السودانيين مجددا للعمل على
الاغلبيه
الوليه للسودان بما يحفظ على وعدته
ومؤسساتي
ويحقق تواعد
شعب الشعب في الامن والسلام والاستقرار
السياسي
والتنموي والاقتصادي خادمه العربيه
للشريفين اصحاب الجلاله
[موسيقى]
والفخامه والسمو حضره السيدات والساده
اننا في منظمه التعاون الاسلامي حريصين
على دعم الجهود لازاله اسباب التوتر
وتحقيق الكلام والامن والاستقرار في اليمن
وليبيا وسوريا ان وحده الاراضي
هذه الدول وسلامتها العقيق
الحفيزه على انصالها الشعوب بها هي
اولويهنا المشتركه كما ندعو الى تعزيز
التضامن مع اشقائنا في الصومال والمساعدات
على تجاوز صعوبات وتطلاع ونطلع على تعزيز
الاخاء والتعاون بين دول
المنطقه المنظمه العربيه كافه واذا انا
نتطلع الى تكثيف التنسيق بين المنظمه
التعاون الاسلامي جامعه الدول العربيه
الدول العربيه لحل القضايا المشتركه
والى تعزيز التعاون في المجالات
الاقتصاديه والعلميه والثقافيه والانسانيه
ويمكن المره
هو تمكين المراه والشباب ومكافحه الارهاب
والتطرف
والتصدي لحفظ خطاب الكراهيه
والاسلاميه وترسيق قيم
التسامح والتفاهم والتعايش السلمي فاننا
نتضح عيدا الى تعزيز
التضامن مع اشقائنا في منظمه الساهل وهارد
بحيره تشاد التي
بينهما والعالم العربي علاقات تاريخيه
وجغرافيه وثقافيه من اجل مساعده مساعدتهم
على مواجهه التحديات الامنيه والتنمويه
ان منظمه التعاون الاسلامي
[موسيقى]
العمل العربي للمشترك ببالغ الاهتمام وانه
لمن دواعي سرورنا ان
تتزامن رئاسه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
للقمه العربيه
برئاسه
رصتهم للقاء الاسلاميه
للقمه الاسلاميه الرابعه عشر وان الوعي
وسرورنا ان
تتزامن رئاسه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
للقمه العربيه
برعاسه
رئاستهم بلقاء الاسلاميه
القمه الاسلاميه الرابعه عشره واننا
لواثقين لعنا هذه الرئاسه ستعطي زخما
للتعاون والتوثيق والجهود من اجل معالجه
القضايا المشتركه والاسهم
معان في اجابه الحلول المناسبه
للتحديات الدوليه في اطار العمل المتعدده
الاطراف واننا نعمل ان
نتكلم اعمال هذه القمه بالنجاح والتوفيق
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر معالي السيد حسين ابراهيم طه على
كلمته وبذلك نختم الاستفتاحيه ونشكر اصحاب
الفخامه والمعالي الضيوف
والان اعلن عن بدء جلسه اعمال القمه وارجو
من الجميع التزام بالوقت المحدد ادعو
جلاله الملك عبد الله الثاني ابن الحسين
ملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه لالقاء كلمته
فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا محمد نبي
العربي الهاشمي الامين اخي صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز اخي خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود وصاحب السمو
الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز السعود على استضافه هذه القمه وعلى
حرص المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه على
تعبير التعاون العربي
كما اشكر الاشقاء في الجزائر على استضافه
القمه السابقه اخواني القاده الحضور
الكرام ان منظومه العمل العربي المشترك
بحاجه دوما الى التطوير والتجديد وهنا
ياتي دور جامعه الدول العربيه في العمل
على تعظيم التعاون وخاصه الاقتصادي بين
دولنا
لمواجهه تحديات الازمات الدوليه
واشير هنا الى اليه تعاون الثلاثي بين
الاردن والاشقاء في مصر والعراق
والشراكه الصناعيه التكامليه لتنميه
اقتصاديه مستدامه والتي تضم الاردن
والامارات ومصر والبحرين بالاضافه الى
مشاريع التعاون المستمره مع الاشقاء في
دول الخليج كامثله لما يمكن تحقيقه بشكل
اوسع اخواني القاده الحضور الكرام لا تزال
القضيه الفلسطينيه محور اهتمامنا ولا يمكن
ان نتخلى عن سعنا لتحقيق السلام العادل
والشامل الذي لن يتحقق اذا لم يحصل الشعب
الفلسطيني الشقيق على حقه في الدوله
الفلسطينيه المستقله ذات السياده على خطوط
الرابع من حزيران عام
1967 وحسبتها
الشرقيه على اساس حل الدولتين لا يمكن
للسلام والامن ان يتحقق مع استمرار بناء
المستوطنات
ومصادره الاراضي وهدم البيوت وتهجير
الفلسطينيه من اراضيهم وتدمير الفرص
المتبقيه لتحقيق حل الدولتين الذي يمنح
الشعب الفلسطيني حقوقه المشروع
فالبديل عن ذلك سيضع المنطقه باكملها على
طريق الصراع المستمر وليس هناك اهم بنسبه
لنا من احترام الوضع التاريخي والقانوني
القائم في المقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه
في القدس المدينه المقدسه التي نكرس كل
امكانياتنا من اجل حمايتها والحفاظ على
هويتها العربيه
الاسلاميه والمسيحيه انط من الوصايه
الهاشميه على هذه المقدسات اخواني القاده
الحضور الكرام لقد حضرنا مرارا من استمرار
ازمه سوريا دون حل فقد دفع الشعب السوري
الشقيق ثمنها غاليا وانعكست اثارها علينا
جميعا
ونرحب اليوم بعوده سوريا الى جامعه
العربيه
كخطوه مهمه نامل ان تسهم في جهود انهاء
الازمه ونؤكد هنا على اهميه تعزيز المسار
السياسي الذي انطلق من اجتماع عمان وبنى
على المبادره الاردنيه والجهود السعوديه
والعربيه
لانهاء الاسباب ومعالجه
ومعالجه تداعياتها الانسانيه والامنيه
والسياسيه لكي يعود اللاجئون الى وطنهم
اخوان القادم لحضور الكرام ان استقرار
العراق استقرار في منطقتنا وامنه جزء من
امنه القومي واننا في هذا الصدد ندعم
الخطوات التي تقوم بها الحكومه العراقيه
بما يعيد
للعراق دوره ومكانته ضمن محيطه العربي
ويعزز استقاره واصدار الازدهاره وسيادته
على اراضيه
ونتطلع
للبناء على مؤتمر بغداد الاول ومؤتمر
بغداد الثاني في تعزيزي التعاون الاقليمي
مع العراق
الاخوه القاده الحضور الكرام لا مجال
للتباطؤ في انتهاز الفرص امامنا تحقيقا
لمصالح بلداننا وشعوبنا لذا فلابد من
تكثيف اللقاءات العربيه الدوريه وعلى اعلى
المستويات لتحقيق التكامل الاقتصادي في
منطقتنا وتوحيد جهودنا السياسيه والامنيه
وفي الختام اجدد شكر لاخيه خادم الحرمين
الشريفين ولحكومه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه ولشعبها العزيز على
استضافه هذه القمه داعيا الله عز وجل ان
يلهمنا النجاح والتوفيق لما فيه الخير
لاوطاننا وشعوبنا والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر زياره الملك عبد الله الثاني بن
الحسين على كلمته والان ندعو فخامه الرئيس
عبد الفتاح السيسي رئيس جمهوريه مصر
العربيه للقاء كلمته فليتفضل بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
اخي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان ابن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد
رئيس مجلس الوزراء لمملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو ملوك
ورؤساء وامراء ورؤساء وحكومات الدول
العربيه الشقيقه معالي السيد احمد ابو
الغيط امين عام جامعه الدول العربيه
السيدات والساده السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
بدايه اتوجه بالشكر لاخي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود ولسمو ولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان ال سعود رئيس مجلس الوزراء على
حفاوه الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه كما اود ان
اعرب عن خالص التقدير للجهود المخلصه التي
بذلها اخي فخامه الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون
رئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه الديمقراطيه
الشعبيه الشقيقه في سبيل دعم العرب العمل
العربي المشترك خلال تراس الجزائر لقمه
العربيه الاخوه الاعزاء لقد مرت منطقتنا
خلال السنوات الاخيره بظروف استثنائيه
قاسيه هدلت على نحو غير مسبوق امن وسلامه
شعوبنا العربيه
واثارت في نفوس ملايين العرب القلق الشديد
على الحاضر والمستقبل
قد تاكد لكل ذي بصيره ان الحفاظ على
الدوله الوطنيه ودعم مؤسساتها فرض عين
وضروره حياه لمستقبل الشعوب ومقدراتها فلا
يستقيموا ابدا ان تظل امال شعوبنا
رهينه للفوضى والتدخلات الخارجيه التي
تفاقم من الاضطرابات وتصيب جهود التسويه
الازمات بالجود
ان الاعتماد على جهودنا المشتركه وقدراتنا
الذاتيه والتكامل فيما بيننا لصياغه حلول
حاسمه لقضايانا اصبح واجبا ومسؤوليه كما
ان التطبيق مفهوم العمل العربي المشترك
يتعين ان يمتد ايضا للتعامل مع الازمات
العالميه وتنسيق عملنا لصاحب منظومه
الحوكمه الاقتصاديه العالميه وفي القلب
منها مؤسسات التمويل وبنوك التنميه
الدوليه التي ينبغي ان تكون اكثر استجابه
لتحديات العالم النامي اخزن في الاعتبار
ان حاله الاستقطاب الدولي اصبحت تهدد
منظومه العولمه التي كان العالم يحتفي بها
وتستدعي للواجهه صراعا لفرد الايرادات
وتكريس المعايير المزدوجه في تطبيق
القانون الدولي اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسموك لقد تابعنا بالحزن والالم تصاعد
حده بعض الازمات العربيه خلال الفتره
الماضيه لا سيما ما ينتج عن اعمال التصعيد
غير المسؤوله من قبل اسرائيل في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واخرها ما شهداه قطاع غزه
وبينما تؤكد مصر استمرار جهودها لتثبيت
التهدئه الا اننا نحذر من ان استمرار
اداره الصراع عسكريا وامنيا سيؤدي الى
عواقب وخيمه على الشعبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي على حد سواء ولعله من الملائم
ان نعيد اليوم تاكيد تمسكنا بالخيار
الاستراتيجي بتحقيق السلام الشامل والعادل
من خلال مبادره السلام العربيه وعلى اساس
قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومطالبه اسرائيل
بناء الاحتلال واقامه دوله الفلسطينيه على
حدود الرابع من يونيو 1967 وعاصمتها القدس
الشرقيه
واشتعلت كذلك ازمه جديده في السودان
الشقيق تنذر اذا لم نتعاون في احتوائها
بصراع طويل وتبعات كارثيه على السودان
والمنطقه كما تستمر الازمات في ليبيا
واليمن بينما بما يفرض تفعيل التحرك
العربي المشترك لتسويه تلك القضاء على نحو
اكثر الحاحا من اي وقت مضى وفي نفس السياق
فان عوده سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه
تعد بمثابه التفعيل العملي للدور العربي
وبدء مسيره عربيه لتسويه الازمه السوريه
استنادا الى المرجعات الدوليه للحل وقرار
مجلس الامن رقم 22 54 اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو مع ادراكنا ان الامن
القومي العربيه هو كل لا يتجزا فقد حان
الوقت لاخذ زمام المبادره للحفاظ عليه بما
في ذلك من خلال الخطوات المهمه الليرات
التي بدرت بها دولنا في الفتره الماضيه
لضبط ايقاع العلاقات مع الاطراف الاقليميه
غير العربيه التي نتطلع منها لخضاه مماثله
وصادقه بما يسهم في تحقيق الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه ختاما يؤكد ان مصر
بمعتموه عنها على الدوام ستدعم بكل صدق
والاخلاص جميع الجهود الحقيقيه لتفعيل
الدور العربي ايمانا منها بان المقاربات
العربيه المشتركه هي الوسيله المسلى
لمراعاه مصالحنا وتوفير الحمايه الجماعيه
لشعبنا ودفع مسيره التنميه خطوات كبيره
للامام شكرا لكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر فخامه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي على
كلمته والان ادعو جلاله الملك حمد عيسى
الخليفه ملكه البحرين القاء كلمته فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الاخ العزيز خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود رئيس القمه
العربيه اخي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير
محمد بن سلمان ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس
مجلس الوزراء
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
الحضور الكرام
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
على بركه الله نجتمع اليوم في ضيافه اخينا
خادم الحرمين الشريفين حفظه الله للنجده
لنجدد العزم
ولنواصل مسيره العمل العربي المشترك
اراده حره
وتصميم ذاتي وبروح التضامن الجماعي المخلص
كي نؤسس للاستقرار والرخاء والوئام الذي
لابد ان تنعم به شعوبنا
وسبيلنا لتحقيق ذلك
نهج السلام العادل والشامل وهو نهج لا
بديل له
لمعالجه كافه القضايا العالقه بضمان الامن
والاستقرار والمصالح الحيويه
لازدهار دول المنطقه دون استثناء
ونرحب اشد الترحيب
بالمساعي العربيه الجاده التي نجد فيها
بوادر مبشره لبلووره نظام اقليمي
متجدد ومتوازن
والمتمثله في استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
واستمرار الهدنه الانسانيه في اليمن
والجهود الجاده لحل ازمتها والجهود الجاده
لحل ازمتها
والعود الحميد للشقيقه سوريا الى بيت
العرب الكبير
ونؤكد على هذا الصعيد ضروره وقف
الاشتباكات المسلحه في السودان
وعوده امنه واستقراره
وحفظ حقوقه المشروعه
الى جانب حقوق الشقيقه مصر في مياه النيل
وبالعمل على استكمال مسيره السلام
للوصول لحل عادل للقضيه الفلسطينيه وهو حل
الدولتين وفق مبادره السلام العربيه
وبما يضمن حق الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق في
اقامه دولته المستقله
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه
ايها الاشقاء نمتنا العربيه
بتاريخها العريق وقيمها الدينيه
والانسانيه
والحضاريه
وما تتمتع به من ثروات بشريه
وكفاءات مبدعه
وموقعا استراتيجي مميز
وموارد طبيعيه متنوعه لا هي قادره على
النهوض
والتقدم لمواكبه حركه العصر
عبر تعزيز التكامل العربي
وبتجديد شراكاتها
الاستراتيجيه مع الدول الحليفه والصديقه
القائمه على حفظ المصالح المشتركه
وبرؤيه توافقيه وسياسات اكثر فاعليه
للتصدي للارهاب
ووقف الحروب وتهديدات اسلحه الدمار الشامل
وصولا لمنطقه مستقره تزدهر في محيطها قيم
التعايش الانساني
والتقارب الديني والحضاري
ومن هنا فاننا نعرب
عن خالص تمنياتنا بان تنجح جهودنا
المشتركه في تحقيق السلام بين روسيا
واكرين كعوده الامن والسلم لشعوب البلدين
والدول المجاوره
وليستعيد العالم عافيته
الاقتصاديه والبيئيه التي تنهكها اله
الحرب
كما ويحدون الامل
بان يحالف التوفيق والنجاح
اعمال مؤتمر الاطراف في اتفاقيه الامم
المتحده الايطاليه
بشان تغيير المناخ كوب 28
الذي سيقام على ارض دوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده الشقيقه في نهايه العام الجاري
باذن الله
واننا اذ نشكر كل من اخينا خادم الحرمين
الشريفين
وصاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس
مجلس الوزراء على هذه الدعوه الكريمه
وعلى حسن الضيافه وكرم الوفاه
نتوجه لهما بعظيم التقدير على ما تبذله
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
من جهود دبلوماسيه فائقه الاهميه
ومبادرات انسانيه عظيمه التاثير
والاثر لعوده امن واستقرار دول المنطقه
وحفظ سيادتها ووحده مواقفها
ولا يفوتنا كذلك
ان نتقدم بالشكر الجزيل الى فخامه الرئيس
عبد المجيد تبون على اسهاماته الطيبه في
تعزيز العمل
العربي المشترك لدى تراس الجمهوريه
الجزائريه الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
اعمال القمه الحاديه والثلاثين
وان نعرب عن خالص الامتنان لمعالي الامين
العام
جامعه الدول العربيه
وجميع منتسب الامانه العامه على حسن
الاعداد والتحضير
لاعمال هذا الاجتماع
سائلين المولى عز وجل
ان تشهد اعمال هذه القمه المباركه
كل توفيق ونجاح
تحقيقا لما نصبو اليه من اهداف خيره تعود
بالمنعه والرفعه لدولنا وشعوبها
كما يطيب لنا ان نعرب في ختام حديثنا
عن ترحيبنا بكم في بلدكم مملكه البحرين
الاجتماعات القمه العربيه المقبله في 20
بعون الله تعالى
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
شكرا الملك حمد بن عيسى الخليفه على كلمته
والان ادعو فخامه الرئيس محمود عباس رئيس
دوله فلسطين لقاء كلمته فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اخي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان
حفظه الله
الاخوه القاده اصحاب الجلاله والسمو
والفخامه
معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
الحضور الكريم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
اتوجه بالتحيه والتقدير لاخي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز حفظه
الله ولكم اخي صاحب السمور الملكي ولي
العهد على استضافه هذه القمه العربيه
التي نثق بانها ستنجح في مواجهه التحديات
الاقليميه والعالميه
التي تواجه امتنا
وتحويلها لفرص تعزز الامن والاستقرار
والسلام في منطقتنا وتحقق طموحات وامال
شعوب امتنا العربيه وفي هذه المناسبه
فاننا نشيد بما حققته المملكه من انجازات
تحت قيادتكم على جميع المستويات على طريق
الرفعه
والنمائي والازدهار كما اتوجه بالش
العرفان لاخي فخامه الرئيس عبد المجيد
تبون رئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه الشعبيه
الديمقراطيه على رئاسته الناجحه للقمه
السابقه
ووجهه بهذه المناسبه تحيه كبار وتقدير
لاشقائنا قاده الدول العربيه
وشعوبها على مواقبهم الثابته تجاه شعبنا
وقضيتنا العادله كما
ونرحب بزياده الرئيس بشار الاسد رئيس
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه اخذ عزيزا بين
اهله
واخوانه الاخ الرئيس
في قرار اممي تاريخيا غير مسبوق احيد
الامم المتحده في مقرها بنيويورك منذ ايام
الذكرى 75 للنكبه نكبه الشعب الفلسطيني
التي لا زالت تتوالى احداثها واثارها
الماساويه منذ العام
1948 حتى يومنا هذا والتي ارتكبت العصابات
الصهيونيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
خلالها اكثر من 51 مجزره موثقه لدينا
ودمرت اكثر من 530 قريه فلسطينيه
موثقه لدينا
ان هذا القرار الاممي التاريخي الهام يشكل
بحضا للروايه الصهيونيه الاسرائيليه التي
تنكرت للنكبه ولفت الروايات المزيفه حول
علاقات الشعب الفلسطيني بارض وطنه
والجرائم التي ارتكبت بحقهم
اننا ايها السيدات والساده نؤكد رفض ذلك
استمرار السباحه سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لارضنا ومقدساتنا ونطالب
المجتمع الدولي بمحاسبه اسرائيل على
جرائمها بحق شعبنا وانتهاكاتها للقانون
الدولي وتوفير الحمايه الدوليه له ونحن من
جانبنا سنواصل مسيرتنا النضاليه لمواجهه
القهر والعدوان الاسرائيلي كما سنواصل
جهودنا دول ماسيه والقانونيه في المحافل
والمحاكم كافه لاستعاده حقوق شعبنا وفي
المقدمه منها المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
ومحكمه العدل الدوليه اضافه الى استمرار
السعي
للحصول على العضويه الكامله في الامم
المتحده وهنا
يعمل منكم جميعا الوقوف الى جانبنا لدعم
تنفيذ قرار الجمعيه العامه الاخير وتقديم
المرافعه
المكتوبه من قبل جوالكم امام محكمه العدل
الدوليه على امل ان تصدر هذه المحكمه
رايها الاستشاري وفتواها حول قانونيه وشكل
واهليه النظام الذي اقامته اسرائيل دوله
الاحتلال والاببارتايد على ارض فلسطين وفي
هذا الصدر نؤكد استعدادنا للعمل مع هذه
القمه العربيه
بقياده المملكه العربيه السعوديه من اجل
انجاح الجهود العربيه والاغلبيه والدوليه
في اطار من الشراكه والتعارون وايجاد حلول
لازمات المنطقه وصولا لتحقيق الامن
والسلام والازدهار لشعوبنا وفي الختام
نتقدم بالشكر والتقدير لاشقائنا قاده
وشعوب امتنا العربيه على مواقفهم السياسيه
ثابته لدعم الشعب الفلسطيني
وعلى السعوديه كافه وكلنا ثقه باستمرار
تقديم هذا الدعم السياسي والمادي لتعزيز
صمود وبقاء الشعب الفلسطيني على ارضه
ومواصله بلا مؤسسات دولته
المستقله واخيرا وليس اخرا نقول لشعبنا
الفلسطيني البطل اننا نفتخر بكم
في كل واحد منكم في الوطن وفي الشتات
ونعتذر ونعتز بمسيرتنا النضاليه وسوف
نواصل العمل من اجل وحده شعبنا وارضنا
وتحقيق المصالحه الوطنيه على اساس
الالتزام بمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
والشرعيه الدوليه والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر فخامه الرئيس محمود عباس على كلمته
والان ندعو فخامه الرئيس محمود ولد الشيخ
رئيس جمهوريه الاسلاميه الموريتانيه
لالقاء كلمتين فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على اشرف المرسلين
اخي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد
رئيس مجلس الوزراء في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيق
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسم
معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
اصحاب المعالي والسعاده الساده والسيدات
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
اود بدايهنا التوجه بالشكر الجزيل الى
خادم الحرمين الشريفين جلاله الملك سلمان
بن عبد العزيز والى ولي عهده رئيس مجلس
الوزراء سمو الامير الملكي محمد بن سلمان
والى الشعب السعودي عموما
على استضافه هذه الدوره الثانيه والثلاثين
الاجتماع مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه وعلى
ما احطنا به من حفاوه استقبال وكرم ضيافه
منذ وصولنا لهذه الارض الطيبه المباركه
كما اهني وجلالته على تسلم رئاسه مجلس
جامعه الدول العربيه
مشيدا بما يطلع به وولي عهده من دور رياضي
وفعال في خدمه قضايا امتنا العربيه
ويطيب لي كذلك انا تقدم بالشكر الجزيل
لفخامه الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون رئيس
جمهوريه الجزائريه الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
على اسلامه في الدفع قدما بالعمل العربي
المشترك خلال رئاسته للدوره الماضيه
ولا يسعني في هذا المقام الى ان انوهها
ايضا بالجهود الدؤوب التي يبلغها سعاده
الامير العام السيد احمد ابو الغيط وفريقه
في سبيل تطوير عملنا العربي
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
ايها الساده والسيدات انما يلوح في خضم
الازمات المتنوعه التي تجتاح العالم من
بوادر تغيرات جيوستراتيجيه عميقه
ليؤكدنا لا يؤكد حاجتنا الماسه الى راس
الصفوف يتجاوز الخلافات لتطوير وترقيه
عملنا العربي المشترك
فبقدر ما يتعزز هذا العمل تتحسن قدرتنا
الجماعيه على الصمود في وجه مختلف
التحديات وكذلك فعاليه جهودنا في تحقيق ما
نطمح اليه من التنميه ومن استقرار
ثم ان عملنا المشترك هو الذي به يقوى
ويتعزز حضورنا على الساحات على الساحه على
الساحات الدوليه سياسيا واقتصاديا وبيئيا
وثقافيا
واود في هذا الاطار انا اجدد رقمنا للجهود
التي تبذلها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه لاستضافه
اهنئ الشقائنا في دوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده على استضافه الدوره القادمه
لمؤتمر اطراف اتفاقيه الامم المتحده
الايطاليه بشان طاير اصحاب الجلال
والفخامه والسمن ايها الساده والسيده ان
احساسي بضروره تطوير عملنا العربي المشترك
يزداد عمقا وقوه كلما نظرت الى الوضع
الراهن في
فلسطين والى ما يشهده عالمنا العربي من
نزاعات وما يواجه من تحديات مصيريه واننا
في الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الموريتانيه
لنودين بقوه الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه ونجدد
التاكيد علامات على تمسكنا بحق
الفلسطينيين في اقامه دوله مستقله عاصمتها
القدس الشرقيه وفقا لما تقتضي به قرارات
الامم المتحده ذات الصله ومبادره السلام
العربي
ونؤكد كذلك تمسكنا بالحلول التي تحفظ
الوحده الترابيه وترسيد عائمه لاستقرار
والامن في كل من ليبيا واليمن مستبشرين
بما يلوح من الفراش في البلدين كما ندعو
في ذات الوقت الى بدر كل الجهود الممكنه
لوقف الاعمال القتاليه بشكل دائم وفعال في
جمهوريه السودان ولخلق ظروف المناسبه
لتقديم الدعم الانساني وللتاسيس لحل سياسي
شامل في هذا البلد الشقيق
وانني لا اشيده هنا بكل الجهود العربيه
المبذوله في هذا الصدد وخاصه بالرعايه
السعوديه الكريمه للمحادثات بين الاطراف
السودانيه الشقيقه
عاملا ان يفضي الاتفاق الذي تم التوصل
اليه الى رسم خارطه طريق تضمن وحده
السودان والسلامه اراضيه وحق مواطنيه في
الامن والاستقرار
واشيد كذلك بعوده جمهوريه سوريا الشقيقه
للحضن للحضن العربي املا لها ان تستعيذ
بشكل كامل دورها المحوري التاريخيه في
تعزيز العمل العربي المشترك ومرحبا باخي
صاحب الفخامه الرئيس بشار الاسد بين
اشقائه اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم
ايها الساده والسيدات
ان العماله العربيه المشترك لا يقوى الا
بقدر قوه الشراكات الاقتصاديه بين بلداننا
العربيه ولذا لابد لنا من تعزيز تبادلاتنا
الاقتصاديه البينيه تمهيدا لقيام سوق
عربيه مشترك تؤسس لتنميه المستديمه وشامله
في فضائنا العربي ومن هذا المنطلق
تنبع لاهميه القصوى التي توليها بلادنا
لانعقاد الدوره الخامسه للقمه العربيه
التنمويه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في
نواكشوط مطلع شهر نوفمبر القادم والتي
يحدون الامل في ان تكون محطه متميزه من
مسيره العمل العربي المشترك وانني ارجل
لاعمال هذه الدوره الثانيه والثلاثين
الاجتماع مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه كل
النجاح والتوفيق لا اعبر لكم مسبقا اخوتي
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسموم السروري
باستقبالكم في نواكشوط لمشاركه فعاليات
القمه العربيه التنمويه في دورتها الخامسه
اشكركم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر فخامه الرئيس محمد ولد الشيخ على
كلمته والان ادعو فخامه الرئيس قيس سعيد
رئيس جمهوريه التونسيه للقاء كلمته
فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والحمد لله رب العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على اشرف الخلق والمرسلين
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسموم معالم امين العام لجامعه
الدول العربيه
اتوجه اولا
في هذه الكلمه الموجزه
باسماع عبارات التهنئه
الى اخي
حضرتي خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ملك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
والى صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود
ولي العهد
ورئيس مجلس الوزراء
راجيا
مبتهلا الى الله
ان توفق اعمالنا وان تسدد خطانا في جمع
الكلمه
ووحده الصف
وانها لمناسبه ايضا في هذا المقام
لتوجيه الشكر الى اخي فخامه الرئيس عبد
المجيد تبون
رئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه الديمقراطيه
الشعبيه الشقيقه
على مدار رئاسته للقمه
بروحا عاليه من المسؤوليه في لم الشمل
والحمد لله تعالى
ان تم لم الشمل
كما توجهوا بالشكر ايضا
الى معاني السيد احمد ابو الغيط امين عام
جامعه الدول العربيه
والى اعظاده على الجهود التي يبذلونها
بدون انقطاع
لتعزيز العلاقات بين
دولنا
وبين
المنظمات
الدوليه الاخرى
ايها الكريم
بعد ان تشكل منذ نهايه القرن التاسع عشر
ودفر ودفع شعبنا العربي
في كل ارجاء وطننا العربي
الثمن باهظا
من اجل الحريه
والانعتاق والاستقلال
وما زرع اشقائنا في فلسطين
يقدمون كل يوما تقريبا
جحافر الشهداء
والجرحى
للتحرر من نير الاحتلال الصهيوني البغيض
هذا فضلا عن الاف الاف اللاجئين الذين لا
يسارون يعيشون في المخيمات
افما اند الانسانيه جماعه
ان تضع حدا لهذه المظلمه
المسلطه على شعبنا في فلسطين في ظل صمت
مريب
لعديد العواصم
ان هذا العالم
الذي هو بصدد التشكل اليوم
لا يجب ان يتشكل مجددا على حساب امتنا
وعلى مقدرات شعبنا
بل نريد ان نكون شركاء على قدم المساواه
مع من يريدون ترتيبه من جديد
فاذا كانت العولمه
التي ظهرت في بدايه السنوات التسعين
ذكرت هذه العولمه قد بلغت بلغت مداها
وانقلبت على عاقبيها
فاننا نرفض ان نكون مره اخرى
ضحايا
لنظاما
عالميا جديد لا نشارك في ارسائه وفي
ترتيبه
وتونس
ثابته على مواقفها
ثابته اولا على استقلال قرارها الوطني
ثابته ايضا على عدم الانخراط في اي تحالف
ضد اخر كما ينص على ذلك دستورها
وشعبها مصر على مبدا المساواه بين الدول
كما تنص على ذلك عديد المواثيق والصكوك
الدوليه
ان التحديات
التي نواجهها كبيره
ولا شك اننا نشترك في نفس الاراده من اجل
رفعها وتخطيها
هذه التحديات
وليست اقلها على الاطلاق
هو الحفاظ على دولنا
لان هناك من يعمل على اسقاطها حتى تغيب
المؤسسات وتعم الفوضى بالاقتتالات
الداخليه
ونحمد الله تعالى
على عوده سوريا على عوده الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه الى احضان جامعه الدول
العربيه
بعد ان تم احباط المؤامره التي كانت تهدف
الى تفتيتها وتقسيمها
ودفع الشعب العربي السوري
الثمن غاليا حتى تبقى سوريا دوله واحده
كما ان ارادتنا هي ذاتها حتى تبقى ليبيا
دوله موحده ويحسم الشعب الليبي امره بنفسه
عن طريق الانتخابات ويعم الامن كل شبر من
اراضيها
ونفس الاداره الاراده عفوا تحدونه
حتى يسترجع اليمن السعيد سعادته بوحده
شعبه وبالقضاء على كل اسباب الفرقه
والانقسام
نفس الامل يخدونه بان يتوقف سفك الدماء
بالسودان الذي قسموه الى الشطرين في
ديسمبر من سنه 10 و2000 فلا نريد سودانا
ثالثا او رابعا اثر هذه الحرب الماساه
وثاني هذه التحديات وليست اقلها حتى وان
وردت بعض التحدي الاول في المقام الثاني
هو الحفاظ على السلم الاهليه
والسلم لن تتحقق الا بالحلول الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
النابعه من اراده الشعب
فبدون القضاء على الفقر وبدون عداله
اجتماعيه لن يتحقق الاستقرار السياسي
المرشود
وانعدام الاستقرار لن يؤثر فقط على
اوطاننا بل سيؤثر حتما على كل الدول
ومن التحديات ايضا ولا يتسع المجال لذكرها
كلها التحدي الثقافي
فبدون ثقافه وبدون تعليم سليمين ونشر قيم
التسامح والتعايش والاعتزاز بل انتماء الى
امتنا لا يمكن ان نحسن مجتمعاتنا ضد من
يتربص بتفكيكها كتربسه بتفكيك الدول
وتقسيمها
ولدينا
من الامكانيات مجتمعين ما يكفي
لتحقيق ما اشترك بالتاكيد في العزم على
تحقيقه وتجسيده في اسرا اوقات بعيدا عن اي
وصفات يريدون املائها علينا من الخارج
فنحن دعاه سلما وسلام ونحن دعاه عدل وحريه
لامتنا
وللامسانيه جمعاء ولا نريد ان تتكرر
الماسي او تستمر كما كانت في الماضي لان
التاريخ
لا خير فيه ان كان سيعيد ما قد ولى وانقضى
وشكرا على الاصغاء والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر فخامه الرئيس قيس سعيد على كلمته
والان ادعو فخامه الرئيس بشار الاسد رئيس
الجمهوريه السوريه العربيه لالقاء كلمته
فليتفضل
سمول امير محمد بن سلمان ولي عهد المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
اصحاب جلاله والسياده والسمو
السيدات والساده
من اين يبدا المرء حديثه والاخطار لم تعد
محلقه بل محققه
يبدا من الامل الدافع للانجاز والعمل
وعندما تتراكم العلل يمكن للطبيب ان
يعالجها فرادى شرط ان يعالج المرض الاساسي
المسبب له
فاذا علينا ان نبحث عن العناوين الكبرى
التي تهدد مستقبلنا وتنتج ازماتنا
كي لا نغرق ونغرق الاجيال القادمه بمعالجه
النتائج لا الاسباب
والتهديدات فيها مخاطر وفيها فرص ونحن
اليوم امام فرصه تتبدل الوضع الدولي الذي
يتبدى بعالم متعدد الاخطاب كنتيجه لهيمنه
الغرب المجرد من المبادئ والاخلاق
والاصدقاء والشركاء
هي فرصه تاريخيه لاعاده ترتيب شؤوننا باقل
قدر من التدخل الاجنبي وهو ما يتطلب اعاده
موضوعنا في هذا العالم الذي يتكون اليوم
كي نكون جزءا فاعلا فيه مستثمرين في
الاجواء الايجابيه الناشئه عن المصالحات
التي سبقت القمه وصولا اليها اليوم
هي فرصه لترسيخ ثقافتنا في مواجهه الذوبان
القادم مع الليبراليه الحديثه التي تستهدف
الانتماءات الفطريه للانسان وتجرده من
اخلاقه وهويته
ولتعريفه هويتنا العربيه ببعدنا الحضاري
وهي تتهم زورا بالعرقيه والشوفينيه بهدف
جعلها في حاله صراع مع المكونات الطبيعيه
القوميه والعرقيه والدينيه فتموت وتموت
معها مجتمعاتنا بصراعها مع ذاتها لا مع
غيرها
العناوين كثيره لا تتسع لها كلمات ولا
تكفيها قمم
لا تبدا عند الجرائم الكيان الصهيوني
المنبوذ عربيا بحق الشعب الفلسطيني
المقاوم ولا تنتهي عند خطر الفكر العثماني
التوسعي المطعم بنكهه اخوانيه منحرفه ولا
تنفصل عن تحدي التنميه كاولويه قصوى
لمجتمعاتنا الناميه
هنا ياتي دور جامعه الدول العربيه
باعتبارها المنصه الطبيعيه لمناقشه
القضايا المختلفه
ومعالجتها شرطه تطوير منظومه عملها عبر
مراجعه الميثاق والنظام الداخلي وتطوير
الياتها كي تتماشى مع العصر
فالعمل العربي المشترك بحاجه لرؤى
واستراتيجيات واهدافها مشتركه نحولها
لاحقا الى خطط تنفيذيه بحاجه لسياسه موحده
ومبادئ ثابته واليات وضوابط واضحه عندها
سننتقل من رد الفعل الى السباق الاحداث
وستكون جامعه متنفسا في حاله الحصار لا
شريكا به ملجا من العدوان لا منصه له
اما عن القضايا التي تشغلنا يوميا من
ليبيا الى سوريا مرورا باليمن والسودان
وغيرها من القضايا الكثيره في مناطق
مختلفه فلا يمكننا معالجه الامراض عبر
معالجه الاعراض
فكل تلك القضايا هي نتائج لعناوين اكبر لم
تعالج سابقا اما الحديث في بعضها فهو
بحاجه لمعالجه التصدعات التي نشات على
الساحه العربيه خلال عقد مضى واستعاده
جامعه لدورها كمرممه لجروح لك معمق لها
والاهم هو ترك القضايا الداخليه لشعوبها
فهي قادره على تدبير شؤونها وما علينا الا
ان نمنع التدخلات الخارجيه في بلدانها
ونساعدها عند الطلب حصرا
اما سوريا فمضيها وحاضرها ومستقبلها هو
العروبه لكنها عروبه الانتماء لا عروبه
الاحضان فالاحضان عابره اما الانتماء
فدائن وربما ينتقل الانسان من حضن لاخر
لسبب ما لكنه لا يغير انتمائه اما من
يغيره فهو من دون انتماء من الاساس ومن
يقع في القلب لا يقبع في حضن وسوريا قلب
العروبه وفي قلبها
السيدات والساده
ونحن ناقل هذه القمه في عالم مضطرب فان
الامل يرتفع في ظل التقارب العربي العربي
والعربي الاقليمي والدولي والذي توج بهذه
القمه والتي اتمنى ان تشكل بدايه مرحله
جديده للعمل العربي للتضامن فيما بيننا
للسلام في منطقتنا للتنميه والازدهار بدلا
من الحرب والدمار والتزاما بالدقائق الخمس
المخصصه للكلمات اتوجه بالشكر العميق
لرؤساء الوفود الذين عبروا عن الموده
المتاصله تجاه سوريا وابادلهم بالمثل كما
اذكر خادم الحرمين الشريفين على الدور
الكبير الذي قام به وجهود المكثفه التي
بذلها لتعزيز المصالحه في منطقه
هذه القمه واتمنى له والاسم ولي العهد
وللشعب السعودي الشقيق دوام التقدم
والازدهار
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اشكر فخامه الرئيس بشار الاسد على كلمته
والان ندعو فخامه الرئيس اسماعيل عمر جيله
رئيس جمهوريه جيبوتي للقاء كلمته فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على اشرف الانبياء
والمرسلين وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين اخي حضره
حاضن الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود ملك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه اصحاب
الجلالة والفخامه والسمو ملوك والرؤساء
وامراء الدول العربيه الشقيقه معالي السيد
احمد ابو الغيث امين عام مدينه امين عام
جامعه الدول العربيه اصحاب المعالي
والسعاده الحضور الكرام السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
انه لا من دواعي السرور ان نجتمع في مدينه
جده عروس البحر الاحمر وبوابه الحرمين
الشريفين واسمحوا لي في مستهل كلمه ان
اعبر عنه خالص الشكر والتقدير والامتنان
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه ملكا
وحكومه وشعبا على ما حضينا به من حفاوه
الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه وعلى الاعداد
المميز لقمتنا هذه كما يطيب لي ان اتقدم
بعميق الشكر الى اخي فخامه الرئيس عبد
المجيد تبون رئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه الشقيقه على ما بدله
من شهود من جهد مقدر خلال فتره الرئاسته
للقمه السابقه والشكر موصول لمعالي الامين
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه وجهاز الامانه
العامه على ما يبدلونه من مساعي حديثه في
سبيل خدمه العمل العربي المشترك اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسموم الحضور الحضور
الكرام يلتزم مجلسنا الموقر في ظل ظروف
دقيقه
وتحديات متشابكه
تفرزها الازمات المتفاقمه في وطننا العربي
والمتغيرات الاقليميه والدوليه المتصارعه
وبالطبع فانه لا سبيل الى مواجهه تلك
التحديات الا من خلال مواقف عربيه موحده
ومتماسكه ترتكز على استراتيجيات واليات
عمل جديد جديا وفعاله تذكر من تلبيه
التطلعات الشعوب العربيه
التوبه الى الوحده والتكامل على جميع
الاصعده وتسهم في ذات الوقت في ايجاد حلول
عمليه الصراعات التي تعصف ببعض دولنا
ويدفع ثمنها الابرياء من ابناء امتنا
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو ان قوتنا
تكمن في وحدتنا
وتماسكنا في دعم القضايا العادله لامتنا
وفي مقدمتها القضيه الفلسطينيه التي تمر
باحلك الظروف في ظل امعاء الامعان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في التنكيل بالشعب
الفلسطيني الشقيق الاعزل
وفي هذا الصدد فاننا نطالب بالزام الدوله
العبريه باحترام القانون الدولي الانساني
ووقف الجرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها وتوفير
حمايه الدوليه للشعب الفلسطيني وتعشيد
الطاقات العربيه وتكثيف الجهود من اجل
اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه قابله للحياه على
حدود الرابع من يونيو لعام 67
وعاصمتها القدس الشريف وفقا لقرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه ذات الصله ومبادره السلام
العربي وفيما يتعلق بسوريا الشقيقه فاننا
نرحب بعوده بعوده هذا البلد العزيز الى
الحضن العربي
معتبرينه ذلك خطوه هامه نحو تعزيز التعاون
العربي المشترك ونثمن الجهود العربيه
المكثفه التي بذلت بهذا الخصوص لمساعده
سوريا على الخروج من ازمتها
وانهاء معاناه الشعب السوري الشقيق التي
امتدت على
مدار الاعوام الماضيه وفيما يتصل باليمن
الشقيق فانما نجدد التاكيد على موقف
جمهوريه جيبوت الثابت الى جانب الشعب
اليمني الشقيق وقيادته الشرعيه على كافه
المستويات معربين عن تفاؤلنا حيال اجواء
السلام التي اضحت تخيم على المنطقه على
خلفيه التقارب بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه والجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه والذي انعش الامال
بخفض التوتر في اليمن وتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار الاقليميه
ونشيد في هذا السياق بجهود حكومه المملكه
لاحياء العمليه السياسيه والتوصل الى حل
سياسي شامل ومستدام وفق المرجعيات المتفق
عليها وتحت اشراف الامم المتحده وحاول
تطورات الوضع في جمهوريه السودان الشقيقه
نؤكد مجددا حرصنا البالغ على امن واستقرار
السودان وسلامه اراضيه كما نعبر على
ترحيبنا بالجهود المحليه والاقليميه
والدوليه الهادفه لوقف اطلاق النار وتهيئه
الظروف الملائمه لحوار سياسي شامل وننوه
في هذا المضمار بالمحادثات الجاريه في جده
بين بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع برعايه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبصفتها عضوا في لجنه الايجاد الايجاد
للمكلفه بالوساطه في الازمه السودانيه فان
جمهوريه جيبوتي ستواصل مساحيها لتنسيق
المواقف مع باقي دول الايجاد المنخرطه في
هذه الوساطه ومع الدول العربيه كذلك
مؤكدين على اهميه التضافر جهود الجميع من
اجل انهاء الازمه في اسرع الوقت وبشان
ليبيا الشقيقه نؤكد دعمنا الكامل للجهود
المبذوله لانهاء الازمه الليبيه عبر تسويه
ليبيه ليبيه بما يحقق المصالحه الوطنيه
ويسمح بتنظيم الانتخابات في اسرع وقت ممكن
ويحفظ وحده ليبيا وسيادتها ويصون مقدراتها
ويلبي طموحات شعبها الشقيق في الامن
والاستقرار والازدهار
وبخصوص المستندات في الصومال فاننا نشيد
باجواء الانفتاح والاستقرار السياسي التي
بدات تباشرها في هذا البلد الشقيق كما
ننوه بالمساعي الذي تبدلها حكومه الرئيس
حسن الشيخ محمود لتحسين الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والامنيه ونؤكد في
الوقت ذاته ان الصومال لا زال بحاجه الى
دعم اشقائه
ومساندتهم له في تحقيق تطلعات شعبه في
الامن والاستقرار والتنميه اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو اصحاب المعالي والسعاده
اننا في هذه المرحله الصعبه والدقيقه من
تاريخ عار من العربي بحاجه الى وقفه جاده
وصادقه للتامل في حال الامه وواقعها
المريض بغيه الدرء المخاطر التي
ما فتنت تزداد تعقيدا وتجديد عزيمه الصمود
من اجل الدفاع عن حقوق شعبنا شعوبنا وصون
مقدراتنا مقدراتها عن حياضها ونحن مفعمون
بالامل والتفاؤل في ظل تولي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه لقياده الدفه
العمل العربي المشترك انطلاقا من ثقلها من
ثقلها ودورها الرياضي وحرصها المعهود على
لم الشمل ونصره قضايا الامه وفي الختام
اجدد الاعراب عن وافر الشكر والتقدير
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه ملكا
وحكومه وشعبا على استضافه هذه القمه
والاعداد الجيد لانجاحها سائنا المولى عز
وجل ان يكلل اعمالنا بالنجاح والتوفيق
وان يوفقنا جميعا لما فيه الخير والصلاح
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر فخامه الرئيس اسماعيل عمر على كلمته
والان ادعو فخامه الرئيس حسن شيخ محمود
رئيس جمهوريه الصومال الفيدراليه القاء
كلمتين فليتفضل
بسم الله الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله
صاحب السموم الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
عبد العزيز ولي العهد رئيس المجلس الوزراء
مملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه رئيس
الدور الثاني والثلاثين لمجلس جامعه
العربيه على مستوى القمه اصحاب الجلال
والفخام والسمو ملوك والرؤساء الدول
العربيه معالي السيد احمد ابو الغيث امين
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه اصحاب المعالي
والسعاده رؤوسا رؤساء الوفود المشاركه
الحضور الكريم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته وبعد
ايها الاخوه الاعزاء
يشرفني ان اتقدم بخالص الشكر والتقدير
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه ملكا
وحكومه وشعبا على كرم ضيافه وحسن
الاستقبال منذ وصولنا الى بلد الحرمين
الشريفين ويساعدني ان
اعبر عن خالص الشكر والتقدير لاخي فقامه
الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون رئيس جمهوريه
الجزائريه
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه الشقيقه رئيس الدوله
السابقه لمجلس جامعه العربيه على مستوى
القمه ونثمن ما بدله من جهود كبير ساهمت
في
تسيير اجتماعاتنا ومتابعه قضايانا العربيه
كما اوجه التهنئه الحاره على صاحب السمو
الملك الملك الملك الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ولي العهد رئيس المجلس
الوزراء المملكه العربيه السعوديه شقيقه
رئيس الدور الثاني والثلاثون لمجلس
الجامعه العربيه على مستوى القمه متمنيا
لقياده النجاح والتوفيق في هذه الدوره
التي نتمنى ان تحقق اهدافنا المنشوده
وتعالج قضايانا فيما يعز اعمارنا العربيه
المشترك
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسموم يطيب لي
اعرب عن سعادتي وسعاده الشعب الصومال
لعوده الجمهوريه السوريه العربيه الشقيقه
الى جامعه العربيه لتمارس دورها التاريخي
في مختلف القضايا العربيه
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسموم
في شان السودان ندرك جميعا ان الاشتباكات
الاخيره بين الجيش وقوات الدعم الصريح امر
مؤلم ومحزن وتضم منا جميعا بدر كافه
الجهود من اجل وضع الجد لهذه الاحداث التي
تحول دون تحقق ما يتضلع له الشعب السوداني
من الامن والاستقرار والازدهار
ونحن نثمن كافه الجهود المبدله لاجل ذلك
سواء من الجهات الدوليه والاقليميه
والعربيه ونقص بالذكر جهود المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه والولايات
المتحده والتي كللت لقاءات بين الطرفين
وامراض اتفاق اتفاقيه هدنه املين ان ينجح
اشقاء السودانيون
في وصول اتفاق السلام دائما يونس صراع
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم اننا في
الصومال منذ تولينا قياده البلاد
قبل عام وضعنا خضه مكونه من ثلاثه بنود
رئيسيه تستند الى كبر التحدياته التي كانت
تواجه الصومال في العقود الاخيره تمثلت في
الاراب من قبل الحركه الشباب والاعتماد
على قوات الاجنبيه تساند قوه قواتنا
الامنيه في استعاده الامن وتراكم الديون
المستحقه التي كانت تشكو عائقا امام امام
اي تنميه ضروريه لنهله البلاد وفي العام
الاول من تولينا الامور تحقق لنا الاتي
اولا في مجال محاربه الارهاب تمكنت قوات
الامنيه الصوماليه من تحرير اكثر من 80
مدينه
في نصف العام وتامين العاصمه من تفجيرات
وعمليات الاغتيال ولا تزال قواتنا المسلحه
وجلسه امنيه تقول حربا على مدار الساعه
ونامل ان في غضون عام من الان للصومال خال
من حركه الشباب الاعرابي الارهابي ثالثا
انسحاب قوات الاتحاد الافريقيه
ولايه اتحاد قوات قوه اتحاد الافريقيه
تنتهي في ديسمبر من عام 2024
ستتمكن القوات الصوماليه من القيام
بالمهام الامنيه قبل هذه التاريخ
ثالثا العفاء عن الديون حيث ابرمت البلاد
اتفاقيه الاعفاء من الديون مع مؤسسات
الدوليه وتمكنا من تنفيذ كافه المتطلبات
وشروط المطلوبه وانا استعمال الرحله
الاعفاء من الديون قبل نهايه العام الحالي
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه وفي الختام نجدد
عزمنا على بدر كل الجهود لخدمه قضايانا
لخدمه قضايا بلداننا
عن عملنا المشترك من التشارك والتشاور
وندعو الله ان يوفقنا لما فيه خير لامتنا
وان يسدد جهودنا التجاوز الاوضاع
الاستثنائيه التي يعيشها وطننا العربي بما
يعزز
امننا واستقرارنا ويحق ما يتضاع اليه
شعوبنا من الازدهار والرقاب واخيرا اقرر
الشكر الاخ صاحب السمو الرئيس المجلس
الرئيس الجلسه ومعالي الاخر لمين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه وكلوا الحاضرين في
هذه الاجتماع الهام
ودمتم في عون الله وحفظه والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر فخامه الرئيس حسن الشيخ محمود على
كلمته والان ادعو سمو الشيخ مشعل لاحمد
الجابر الصباح ولي عهد دوله الكويت للقاء
كلمته فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
[موسيقى]
صاحب السمو الملكي
الاخ العزيز الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
الوزراء بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه في
الشقيقه اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
معالي السيد احمد ابو الغير الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه
اصحاب المعالي والسعاده السيدات والساده
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يطيب لي ممثلا عن حضره صاحب السمو
الشيخ نواف الاحمد الجابر الصباح امير
دوله الكويت حفظه الله ورعاه ان انقل لكم
جميعا تحياتي سموه وتمنياته لكم بالتوفيق
والسداد في كل ما فيه خير خير امتنا
العربيه وخدمه قضاياها العادله
كما يطيب لي ان اتقدم بالتهنئه الى قياده
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه على
رئاستها لاعمال هذه القمه في دورتها
الثانيه والثلاثين
معربين عن ثقتنا بانما تحظى به من خبره
وحكمه سيكلل اعمالنا بالنجاح والتوفيق
شاكرين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه قياده وحكومه وشعبا على ما احطنا
به من كرم ضيافه وما شاهدناه من اعداد
مميزا لهذا اللقاء الهام كما اشكر اخي
العزيز فخامه الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون رئيس
الجمهوريه الجزائريه الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
الشقيقه على ما بدله من جهود خلال رئاسته
لاعمال قمتنا السابقه ولا يفوتنا الاشاره
بجهود معاني الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه السيد احمد ابو
الغيظ وجهاز الامانه العامه لجامعه الدول
العربيه على اعداد لقائنا ومتابعته
الحضور الكرام اننا نشعر بالتفاؤل لبوادر
الانفراجات الحاصله في المنطقه ومنها
البيان المشترك بين كل من المملكه العربيه
السعيد الشقيقه والجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه الصديقه برعايه جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه الصديقه
مؤكدين ان هذه التفاهمات ستنعكس ايجابا
على استقرار المنطقه وازدهارها وتحقيق
تطلعات شعوبها الا ان التفاؤل يمتزج
بالقلق حيال استمرار بعض التحيات بعض
التحديات التي يواجهها وطننا العربي اذ
ياتي اجتماعنا اليوم في ظل تطورات متسارعه
تحيط بدولنا العربيه والتي تنعكس بلا شك
على امن منطقتنا واستقرارها كما ان
استمرار بعض الاضطرابات في العالم ومنها
يحدث في اوكرانيا له تبعات خطيره على
الامن والسلم الدوليين الامر الذي يحتم
علينا وضع التصورات والاليات المناسبه
للتعامل مع هذه التطورات والتحديات
وفيما يتعلق بشان السوري فان دوله الكويت
تجدد تاييدها لقرار مجلس جامعه الدول
العربيه رقم ثمانيه تسعه واحد اربعه
وترحيبها كذلك بالبيان الصادر في اعقاب
اجتماع جده والبيان الصادر عن اجتماع عمان
وكلنا امل في ان تكون عوده سوريا الى بيت
العرب منطلقا بانتهاء الازمه ومعاناه
الشعب السوري الشقيق وفي هذا الشان تؤكد
دوله الكويت موقفها المبدئي الثابت الداعي
الى الحفاظ على وحده وسياده سوريا وسلامه
اراضيها ورفض اي تدخل في شؤونها الداخليه
وموقفنا المستمر منذ بدايه الاحداث بتقديم
الدعم الانساني لكافه اطياف الشعب السوري
متطلعين في هذا الصدد الى التزام الحكومه
السوريه بما تضمنه بيانا بيانا جده وعمان
وقرار مجلس الامن رقم اثنين اثنين خمسه
اربعه وبما يضم عوده سوريا لممارسه دورها
الطبيعي المؤثر في محيطها العربي
والاقليمي والدولي
الحضور الكرام ستبقى القضيه الفلسطينيه
على راس الاولويات والتحديات التي تواجه
امتنا العربيه ونود التاكيد هنا على موقف
دوله الكويت الثابت الداعم لحقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني الشقيق في مواجهه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وعدوانه وجرائمه التي تمس
الوضع التاريخي لمدينه القدس كما ندعو
المجتمع الدولي الى القيام بدوره لاعاده
احياء عمليه السلام وصولا الى حل عادلا
شاملا وفق ما نصه عليه قرارات الشرعيه
الدوليه ومبادره السلام العربيه
وبما يضمن حق الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق في
اقامه دولته المستقله على ارضه وعاصمتها
القدس الشرقيه وختاما فان امام دولنا
العربي المسؤوليات وتحديات جسام تتطلب منا
جميعا بدل المزيد من الجهود وتنسيق
المواقف لضمان مستقبل امن مستقر في كافه
ربوع وطننا العربي متمنيا لاعمال هذه
القمه كل التوفيق والسداد والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الاخ العزيز صاحب السمو الملكي الامير
محمد بن سلمان ال سعود ولي العهد ورئيس
مجلس الوزراء في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه الساده اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسمو معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه
السيدات والساده الحضور السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
بدء اسمحوا لي ان اتقدم بالشكر الجزيل
لخادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز وولي عهده الامير محمد بن
سلمان ال سعود وللشعب السعودي الشقيق
لاستضافه وتنظيم هذه القمه
والشكر موصول للاخ الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون
وللجزائر الشقيقه على حسن ادارتها للقمه
بدورتها السابقه
الحضور الكريم
يسعدني هناك ان ارحب بعوده سوريا الشقيقه
الى مكانها الطبيعي وهي خطوه اكدنا عليها
ودعمناها منذ البدايه
لاعتقادنا باهميتها على طريق اعاده
الاستقرار في المنطقه
ومن منطلق الشعور بالمسؤوليه تجاه كل
اشقائنا في البلدان العربيه نشدد على
اهميه العمل العربي المشترك من اجل احتواء
الخلافات ومن واجبنا هنا ان لا ندع
السودان الشقيق ينزلق الى اتون الانشقاق
والتناحر الداخلي
ونرحب بمبادرات التي تدعو الى انهاء
الاقتتال هناك
ونامل ان تنجح الجهود لتحقيق الاستقرار في
ليبيا الشقيقه
مثلما نستبشر خيرا باستمرار محاولات تحقيق
السلام في اليمن الشقيق
ونجدد وقوفنا مع اشقائنا في لبنان من اجل
تجاوز الظروف السياسيه والاقتصاديه كما
نشدد على موقف العراق الثابت والمبدئي
ازاء الحق الفلسطيني في الارض والسياده
وباقامه دوله عاصمتها القدس الشريف ولا
يفوتنا هنا ان نذكر العالم ان المقدسات ما
زالت تنتهك هناك بما لا يقبله الضمير
الانساني
نستثمر وجودنا هنا لنعرب عن الترحيب
بالاتفاق بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه وهي خطوه
عمليه دعمها العراق وعمل على تحقيقها
باستثمار النوايا الطيبه من البلدين
الجارين خدمه للاستقرار والازدهار في
المنطقه
ان التفاف العرب حول بعضهم لا ينبغي ان
يفهم على انه انعزال بل يمكن ان يزيدنا
ذلك انفتاحا على جيراننا كعرب مجتمعين
وكدول عربيه منفرده
وانني ادعو الجامعه العربيه الى تطوير
مناهجها نحو بناء تكتل اقتصادي من شانه
تعزيز اقتصادياتنا واستثمار مواردنا
المختلفه بافضل وجه
لقد استطاعت دول عديده ان تبني تكتلات
اقتصاديه ناجحه وهي لا تملك من العناصر
المشتركه بين اعضائها شيئا بل لا تملك لغه
مشتركه حتى لذا يتوجب علينا جميعا ان
نتحرك كل زوايا الترابط والتكامل
الاقتصادي بين بلداننا وعلى هذا المسار
سنستضيف في العراق مؤتمرات عده لوضع الحجر
الاساس لمثل هذا التعاون منها مؤتمر بغداد
للتكامل الاقتصادي والاستقرار الاقليمي
كما تتهيا العاصمه بغداد هذه الايام
لاحتضان مؤتمر طريق التنميه ذلك المشروع
الواعد الذي سيعزز الروابط والمصالح
الجامعه لشعوبنا
وحين نتحدث عن التنميه المستدامه يتوجب
الوقوف عند التغيرات المناخيه وشح المياه
هذا الملف الذي يتطلب منا عملا مشتركا في
ضوء القوانين والاعراف الدوليه لايجاد
حلول جذريه تخفف من الاثار السلبيه لهذا
التحدي الحقيقي
السيدات والساده ان شعبان من الشعوب
الشابه وهذه حقيقه تضيف الينا مسؤوليه
حساسه ومن هنا فان افه المخدرات وما
يوازيها من محاولات للتاثير الثقافي
والقيم تتطلب منا موقفا حاسما ينطلق من
التكاتف والتعاون لمكافحه هذه الافه
لقد وقف اخوتكم في العراق وقدموا ابلغ
التضحيات لحمايه العراق والمنطقه والعالم
من خلال تصديهم للهجمه الارهابيه الهمجيه
وذلك الانتصار الذي حققناه يدفعنا قدما
للمضي لبناء بلدنا وتحقيق ما يصبو له
ابناء شعبنا في التنميه والرخاء الاخوه
واصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو اتقدم لكم
جميعا بالدعوه لعقد القمه العربيه لعام 25
في بغداد دار السلام التي تتطلعه لاحتضان
الاشقاء العرب في بلاد الرافدين في الختام
اجدد الشكر للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه لحفاوه الاستقبال وحسن الضيافه
واتمنى لهذه القمه الموفقيه والنجاح لما
فيه مصلحه شعوبنا العربيه وشعوب المنطقه
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
رئيس الوزراء في الجمهوريه اللبنانيه
للقاء كلمته فليتفضل
صاحب السمو الملكي ولي عهد المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الامير محمد بن سلمان
اصحاب الجلاله والسمو والفخامه والسياده
معالي الامين العام للجامعه الدول العربيه
الشكر اولا للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
قياده وشعبا على احتضانها قاده العرب على
ارضها المباركه وقد جاءوا حاملين فيها
امال شعوبهم والامهم
ومطلعين الى تحقيق غدا افضل لهم في ظل
رئاسه المملكه للدوره الحاليه للقمه
والشكر موصول ايضا الى الجزائر الشقيقه
على كل الجهود التي بذلتها خلال تراسها
الدوره السابقه
من الجزائر التي عملت بثبات وهدوء لرم
الشمل الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه حاضنه
العرب كل العرب والتي نثق بحكمه قيادتها
وقدرتها على اعاده وصل منقطع بين اخوه
يجمعهم اكثر بكثير مما يفرقهم
اسمحوا لي ان اسمي هذه القمه قمه تضمير
الجراح حيث سبق انعقادها اتفاقا لاعاده
العلاقات الى طبيعتها بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
وايضا تثمين عوده الشقيقه الثوريه الى
القيام بدورها كاملا في جامعه الدول
العربيه
المشكلات والقضايا العربيه نعرفها جميعا
من ماسك من ماساه فلسطين الى اليمن ومؤخرا
الى وضع المؤسف في السودان ولكن انا اريد
ان اتحدث عن وطني لبنان الذي يستمر في
معاناته من ازمات متعدده ارحب بثقلها على
الشعب اللبناني الذي يعيش سنوات سنوات
عجاف يعاني فيها يوميا ما يعانيه من فقدان
المقومات الاساسيه المعنويه والماديه التي
تمكنه من الصمود
وقد ازدادت هذه الحاله تعقيدا بشغور سده
الرئاسه الجمهوريه وتعذر انتخاب رئيس جديد
اضافه الى ان لبنان لم يتوانى يوما عن فتح
ابوابه امام اخواننا النازحين السوريين
ايمانا باخوه الشعبين وتقدم الاعتبارات
الانسانيه على ما عداها
لكن طول امد الازمه وتعثر معالجتها وتزايد
اعداد النازحين بشكل كبير يجعل من ازمه
النزوح اكبر من طاقه لبنان على التحمل لا
من حيث بناه تحتيه ولا من حيث التاشيرات
الاجتماعيه والارتدادات السياسيه في
الداخل ولا من حيث الحق الطبيعي لهؤلاء
النازحين بالعوده الى مدنهم وقراهم هي
عوده لا يمكن ان تتحقق اذا لم تتضافر
الجهود العربيه مع مؤازره من المجتمع
الدولي وبالتواصل والحوار مع الشقيقه
السوريه في اطار موقف عربي جامع عبر
مشاريع بناء وانعاش للمناطق المهدمه لوضع
خارطه الطريق لعوده الاخوه السوريين الى
ديارهم
في هذا في هذا اللقاء لابد من تاكيد
احترامي لبنان لكافه القرارات الدوليه
المتتاليه الصادره عن مجلس الامن الدولي
وقرارات الجامعه العربيه وميثاقها
والالتزام بتنفيذ منتدى درجاتها وانا اؤكد
ايضا باسمي كل لبنان احترام مصالح الدول
الشقيقه وسيادتها وامنها الاجتماعي
والسياسي ومحاربه تصدير الممنوعات اليها
وكل ما يسيء الى الاستقرار فيها هو التزام
التزام ثابت ينبع من احساس بالمسؤوليه
تجاه اشقائنا ومن حرصنا على امنهم
وسلامتهم وصفاء العلاقات الاخويه معهم
وصدقها
صاحب السموم من استطاع نقل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وشبابها الى المواقع
القياديه والرياديه التي وصلوا اليها
وتحويل المملكه الى بلد منتج بكل مليء
كلمه من معنى في فتره قصيره ليس صعبا عليه
ان يكون العضد لاشقائه في لبنان ومن هنا
فانا اطلع الى رعايه المملكه ولفتتها
الاخويه تجاه بلدي لبنان ليتمكن من النهوض
من جديد ختاما اكرر شكر لبنان للدول
الشقيقه وخاصه اعضاء التعاون الخليجي على
اتاحه فرص عمل للبنانيين على اراضيها وضمن
مؤسساتها الخاصه والعامه فلولا هذه
الرعايه لكان وضع لبنان المالي والاقتصادي
والاجتماعي اشد قساوه والى من ولابد لي
ايضا من هنا عن هذا المنبر ان اشكر
جمهوريه العراقيه على ما تقدمه دائما من
اجل لبنان وكم نتمنى من الاخوه العرب
عودتهم سريعا جميعا الى لبنان في هذا
الصيف وبعد قال تعالى في كتابه العزيز
سنشد وعضدك باخيك صدق الله العظيم فشدوا
ايها الاصدقاء عدد لبنان الذي سيبقى
برعايتكم وكما عهدتموه جامعا للعرب
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اشكر دوله الرئيس نجيب ميقاتي على كلمته
والان ادعو صاحب اسمه السيد اسعد بن طارق
ال سعيد نائب رئيس الوزراء لشؤون العلاقات
والتعاون الدولي وممثل الخاص لجهات
السلطان عمان للقاء كلمته
اهل الرحمن الرحيم
خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود ملك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
رئيس الدوره الثانيه والثلاثين لمجلس
جامعه الدول العربيه على مستوى القمه
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
ضيوف القمه العربيه الكرام والحضور الكريم
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
نطيب لي في مستهل هذا الجمع المبارك
ان انقل لكم تحيات حضره صاحب الجلاله
سلطان هيثم بن طارق المعظم سلطان عمان
وتمنياته الصادقه
ودعمه ومساندته لاعمال القمه العربيه
الثانيه والثلاثين
على ارض المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
برئاسه اخاه خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز
والذي بحكمته واخوانه قالت الدول العربيه
نرى في سلطنه عمان
وبالتوفيق من الله سبحانه وتعالى بان نجاح
هذه القمه قد تحقق بالتئام
بالتئام شمل الامه
العربيه ولله الحمد والفضل
الشكر والتحيه لجهود خادم الحرمين
الشريفين المخلصه
والمبادرات الناجحه ولاخوانه من القاده
العرب في سبيل الاحياء التضامن العربي
وانهاء زمات المنطقه بحلول عربيه
والمضي الى مرحله مشرقه في مسيره الامه
بما يعود بمشيئه الله بالنفع على دولنا
وشعوبنا وامتنا العربيه
ودون شك على غيرنا من الدول العالم
من دول العالم لما يمثله عالمنا العربي من
ثقل هام على مستوى العالم
ولا يفوتنا هنا ان نعرب عن شكرنا لمعالي
احمد بن الغيط الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه والجهاز الامانه العامه على
جهودهم في التحضيرات المثمره لهذه القمه
ودورهم البناء في تطوير منظومه العمل
العربي المشترك
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمور وسائل
الوفود
لقد اكد اراده سلطان هيثم بن طارق سلطان
عمان في اول خطاب بعد توليه الحكم
بالاستمرار في دعم جامعه الدول العربيه
والتعاون مع زعماء الدول العربيه والرقي
بحياه المواطنين
والنيب هذه المنطقه عن الصراعات والخلافات
والعمل على تحقيق تكامل اقتصادي يخدم
تطلعات الشعوب العربيه
ومن تلكم المباري والغايات فيسعدنا ان
نرحب باستئناف مشاركه الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه الشقيقه
الفاعله في اعمال جامعه الدول العربيه
معربين عن الارتياح لحضور ومشاركه فخامه
الرئيس بشار الاسد في هذه القمه مع اليقين
التام بان سوريا الشقيقه
ستستعين بعون الله وبعزمه رجالا رجلها
ونسائها وشبابها مكانتها كحاضره تاريخيه
ومنار عربيه مشهود لها بذلك
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسمور وسالهول
اننا في سلطنه عمان وكغيرنا من الدول
والشعوب المحبه للعدل والسلام
نعتقد بان عجز المجتمع الدولي يعني جاد
تسويه عن التسويه العادله والمنصه
والمنصفه لمعانات الشعب الفلسطيني هو منبع
التوترات التي تعصف من حين الاخر
بالمنطقه والعالم
اذ لا يمكن ان نؤمل نامل بمستقبل للشعوب
يكمن في التعايش والاستقرار دون تطبيق
مبادئ ومعايير القانون الدولي
وقرارات الشرعيه الدوليه تجاه القضيه
الفلسطينيه ومنح حق الشعب الفلسطيني
باقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه المستقله
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه وعلى خطوط الرابع
من يونيو
1967 وفقا لقرارات مجلس الامن الصادره في
هذا الشان مبادره السلام العربيه ومبدا
الارض مقابل السلام
اننا على يقين تام بان الحفاظ على جامعه
الدول العربيه وتطويرها سيعزز من على
التعاون والتكامل
وتبادل المنافع فيما بين دولنا وكذلك مع
مختلف دول العالم
مستلهمين الموروث الحضاري للامه العربيه
وتاريخ التليد وما قدمته للبشريه في مختلف
العلوم والمعارف
ولنؤكد حقنا باننا قادرون بكلمه سوى على
ان نخطو بانفسنا والرقي بدولنا الى افاق
ارحب
ازدهارا ونماء والمضي بشعوبنا الى مكانتها
اللائقه بين الامم
وختاما يسرنا ان نتقدم بجزيل الشكر
والتقدير الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه وحكومه حكومه وشعبا على حسن
الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه وعلى حسن التنظيم
لنجاح هذه القمه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
اشكر صاحب السمو السيد اسعد بن طارق سعيد
على كلمته والان ادعو فخامه الرئيس
محمد يونس المنيفي رئيس المجلس الرئاسي
الليبي القاء كلمه فليتفضل
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء رئيس القمه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسموع معالي السيد احمد ابو الغيط امين
عام جامعه الدول العربيه
السيدات والساده يطيب لي ان اعرب عن خالص
الشكر وعظيم الامتنان الى خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز والى
حكومه المملكه على كرم الضيافه وحفاوه
الاستقبال منذ ان وقعت اقدامنا هذه الارض
الطيبه المباركه واهنئكم على توليكم رئاسه
القمه كما تقدم بالشكر والتقدير لفخامه
الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون لما بذله من جهود
دعوبا ومميزه خلال ترى راسه فتره الدوره
السابقه
انه لمن دواعي اهتزازنا بالقوه العربيه
المتابعه الدائمه لجامعه الدول العربيه
على مستوى القمه وعبر كل هياكل الجامعه
للاوضاع في ليبيا والتي تتجلى في جمله
القرارات المتخذه بشان الاوضاع في ليبيا
على مر السنوات الاثنى عشر الاخيره وهو ما
يجعلنا نطمح الى دور اوسع واوضح للجامعه
العربيه من خلال دعم جهود ودور الاتحاد
الافريقي والامم المتحده في تحقيق
المصالحه الوطنيه الشامله وانجاز
الاستحقاق الانتخابي بانتخابات برلمانيه
ورئاسيه خلال العام الحالي عشرين 23 ووضع
ترتيبات ماليه لاداره الايرادات
والمصروفات للدوله الليبيه بملكيه وطنيه
خالصه وفي اطار الجهود المبذوله لتوطيد
الاستقرار والامن يواصل المجلس الرئاسي
لاشراف بالتنسيق مع بعثه الامم المتحده في
ليبيا على عمل لجنه خمسه زائد خمسه لتوحيد
المؤسسه العسكريه وتستمر على الصعيد
السياسي مساعينا الجاده بالتعاون والتنسيق
مع الاطراف المحليه وبعثت الامم المتحده
للدعم في ليبيا التي من ضمنها دعم خطوات
التي يقوم بها مجلسين نواب والدوله من
خلال لجنه سته زائد سته التي اوكل لها
المجلس التوافق حول القوانين الانتخابيه
السيدات والساده اننا في ليبيا ندعم كل
الجهود الفرديه والجماعيه لتحقيق التضامن
العربي وراء بالصدع ونبذ الخلافات بين
بلداننا وفي هذا الصدد نثني على جهود
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه في لم
الشمل العربي الذي ادى الى انعقاد هذه
القمه بكامل اعضائها كما نبارك ونؤيد
جهودها الهادفه للوصول الى حل شامل
مقبول ومستدام في اليمن الشقيق ينهي
الازمه بالتوافق بين الحكومه الشرعيه
والحوثيين كما اننا نبدي استعدادنا الى
الانخراط في الجهود المبذوله في حل الازمه
السودانيه بما يؤدي الى انهاء الاقتتال
بين الاخوه وبما يحفظ الاستقرار في
منطقتنا اصحاب جلاله والفخامه والسمو من
خلال هذا المنبر ندعو اشقائنا العرب لتبني
موقف موحد اتجاه الاوضاع في ليبيا وعلى
راسها رحيل كافه المرتزقه والمقاتلين
الاجانب والقوات الاجنبيه عن الاراضي
الليبيه ووقف التدخلات السلبيه وغير
البناعه ودعم المسار الديمقراطي والتداول
السلمي للسلطه كما نجدد تاكيدنا على ضروره
توظيف اي حوار لاستكمال تنفيذ خارطه
الطريق المنبثقه عن الحوار السياسي وتحقيق
هدفها الى تعزيز الشرعيه السياسيه
الانتخابات برلمانيه ورئاسيه والابتعاد عن
كل من شانه زياده الانقسامات في ليبيا
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والصمون شعبكم
الشقيق في ليبيا ارتبط وجدانيا بقضيه
العرب المركزيه القضيه الفلسطينيه منذ
اللحظه التي نهض فيها الشعب الفلسطيني
والشعوب العربيه لمقاومه مشاريع الاستيطان
في اراضي فلسطين التاريخيه واننا ندعو في
هذا الاطار الى تنفيذ كافه قرارات جامعه
العربيه الداعيه الى دعم صمود وحقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني وحقه في اقامه دولته المستقله
وفق قرارات الامم المتحده ذات الصله ويظل
موقف دوله ليبيا ثابتا وراسخا في دعم شعب
الفلسطيني ومسانده نضاله وكفاحه حتى ينال
حقوقه المشروعه ورفض اي تغيير على الوضع
القانوني لمدينه القدس بالاضافه الى عدم
الاعتراف باي قرارات احاديه تؤدي الى عرقل
جهود السلام كما ما يتعرض له المسجد
الاقصى من اقتحامات وتعديات تقبل اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسمو واصحاب المعالي
والسعاده والسيدات والساده تمنياتي لكم
بموفور الصحه والعافيه والسداد ولبلداننا
الشقيقه التقدم والازدهار ولاخواننا في
السعوديه التقدير والامتنان في ظل قياده
خادم الحرمين الشريفين ووريعاده صاحب
السمو الملكي رئيس المجلس الوزراء الامير
محمد بن سلمان اشكركم والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
اشكر فخامه الرئيس محمد يونس على كلمته
والان ندعو فخامه الرئيس الدكتور رشاد
العليمي رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسيه في
الجمهوريه اليمنيه للقاء كلمته فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اخي صاحب السمو الملكيه الامير محمد بن
سلمان
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه رئيس القمه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو معالي الام
من العام لجامعه الدول العربيه احمد ابو
الغيط اصحاب المعالي والسعاده السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اسمحوا لي في المستهل كلمتي ان اعرب عن
خالص الشكر والتقدير للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه بقياده اخي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي
عهده صاحب السمو الملكيه الامير محمد بن
سلمان على الاستضافه الكريمه لهذه القمه
وعلى ما حضينا به من كرم الضيافه وحسن
الاستقبال والرفاده وجهودهم والوفاده
وجهودهم المشهوده من من اجل وحده الامه
والدفاع عن مصالحها
وتطلعاتها في التنميه والاستقرار والسلام
كما اتوجه بالشكر والتقدير الى الاشقاء في
الجزائر قياده وحكومه وشعبا على ما بدلوه
من جهد خلال رئاستهم للدوره السابقه في
مرحله عصيبه من تاريخ امتنا
واغتنموا الفرصه ايضا لاعرب عن تقديرنا
الكبير لجهود الامين العام لجامعه الدول
للجامعه الدول العربيه احمد ابو الغيط
ومساعديه وفريق عمله في مؤازره ومناصره
قضيه شعبنا وحقه في استعاده مؤسسات الدوله
وانهاء الانقلاب وانهاء انقلاب الميليشيات
الحوثيه المدعومه من النظام الايراني وهو
امتنان موصول لكم ايها الاشقاء على
مواقفكم الثابته من القضيه اليمنيه وفي
المقدمه دول تحالف دعم الشرعيه بقياده
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ودوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده التي سطرت على ارضنا
واحده من اع ظم الملاحم العربيه في ردع
التهديدات المحدقه بالامه خلال العصر
الحديث وهو شكرا ايضا للاشقاء في مصر
والاردن الذين فتحوا ابواب بلدانهم
لاستقبال مئات الالاف من ابناء شعبنا
الباحثين عن ملاذ امن من بطش الميليشيات
وتسهيل فرص حصولهم على العلاج والتعليم
والعيش الكريم
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسبل اصحاب
المعالي تنعقد هذه القمه في وقت ما يزال
فيه شعبنا يعاني ويلات الحرب التي اشعلتها
الميليشيات الحوثيه منذ انقلابها على
التوافق الوطني في سبتمبر 2014 بدعم من
النظام الايراني المستميت من اجل استكمال
مشروعه التدمير في المنطقه مع استمرار
انقسام منظومتنا العربيه وعجزها عن
الاستجابه للازمات والنزاعات المسلحه التي
تهدد بانهيار الدوله الوطنيه
وتجريفها لصالح المشاريع الخارجيه
التوسعيه الدخيله على مجتمعنا وهويتنا
العربيه وتراثنا للحضاري والاجتماعي وانني
امن ان نستلهم من صمود شعوبنا وتضحياتها
الجسيمه في مقاومه تلك المشاريع لاحداث
التحول المنشود واستثمار اجتماعاتنا هذه
في استعاده المبادره والتوافق
السياسات المشتركه التي تستجيب لاراده
الامه وتعلي مصالحها وتضعها فوق كل اعتبار
لذلك نحن على ثقه بان تمثل قمه جده في ارض
الحرمين المباركه منعطفا هاما لاقرار
السبل الكثير تجاوز تحدياتها باداره
واراده عربيه خالصه اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسموم اصحاب المعالي والسعاده
بعد نحو سبع اشهر على انعقاد قمه الجزائر
وما نزال وما تزال تلك الامان التي
حملناها اليكم بتجديد الهدنه تواجه تعنتا
من قبل الميليشيات الحوثيه دون اقتراس
لمعاناه الملايين من مواطنينا في الداخل
والخارج وها نحن اليوم من جديد نترقب ثمار
المساعي الحديثه التي يقودها الاشقاء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وسلطنه عمان
لاحياء ذات الهدنه التي التزم نا
باستمرارها من طرف واحد حرصا على انهاء
معاناه شعبنا وتفويت اي فرصه للمليشيات في
العوده الى التصعيد الشامل
وبدلا من ابداء حسن النوايا تجاه
المبادرات الحكوميه تواصل تلك الميليشيات
للشهر الثامن على التوالي منعا وصول السفن
والناقلات التجاريه الى موانئنا سعيا منها
لسحق المكاسب المحققه في المحافظات
المحرره بما في ذلك انتظام دفع مروات
الموظفين واعاقه فرص توسيعها لتشمل
الموظفين في المناطق الخاضعه بالقوه
لسيطره الميليشيات كما تستمر تلك
الميليشيات في تهديداتها لدول الجوار
والسلم والامن الدوليين لنشر مزيد من
الطائرات الايرانيه المسيره والالغام
البحريه والقوارب المفخخه والانتهاكات
الجسيمه لحقوق الانسان التي يرويها لنا
كقصص من الجحيم ابناؤنا الذين تنفسوا هواء
الحريه في عمليات تبادلا للمحتجزين بعد
سنوات من التعذيب والاخفاء القسري
وفوق وفوق ذلك تعمل تلك الميليشيات في
الوقت الراهن على حشد اكثر من مليون طفل
الى معسكرات تعبويه متطرفه من شانها تدمير
نسيجنا الاجتماعي وقيم التعايش التي
انتهجها شعبنا اليمني على مر التاريخ
ولذلك ايها الاخوه فاننا نامل تحركا عربيا
جماعيا الى جانب شقهنا في دول تحالف دعم
الشرعيه من اجل وقف تلك الانتهاكات
للفظيعه للقانون الدولي
ولقيام الاسلام والحريه والمساواه ودعم
جهود الحكومه اليمنيه لانعاش الاقتصاد
وتحسين الخدمات الاساسيه والتدخلات
الانسانيه المتقده للحياه ومبادرات
الاشقاء والاصدقاء الاستئناف العمليه
السياسيه بموجب مرجعيات المبادره الخليجيه
واليتها التنفيذيه ومخرجات مؤتمر الحوار
الوطني الشامل وقرارات مجلس الامن ذات
الصله وخصوصا القرار واحد سته اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسموم لقد رحمنا بحذر
في مجلس القياده الرئاسي والحكومه
بالاتفاق بين اشقائنا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وايران على امل ان يؤدي ذلك الى
مرحله جديده من العلاقات الايجابيه في
المنطقه التي تصب في مصلحه الشعب الايراني
ووقف مغامرات نظامه المدمره والتوقف عن
التدخل في شؤوننا الداخليه وانني يقترن
هذه الفرصه لاشود بجهود الدول الاعظه
والامانه العامه لجامعه الدول العربيه
التي افضت الى استهداف مشاركه الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه في اجتماعات مجلس الجامعه
على طريق حل الازمه السوريه وفقا للمبدا
الخطوه مقابل الخطوه وبما يضمن وحده
وسلامه البلد الشقيق والسعاده دوره
التاريخي في العمل العربي المشترك
بجهود المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي تكللت بتوقيع
الاشقاء في السودان على اعلان مبادئ
لتامين الاعمال الانسانيه وحمايه المدنيين
تمهيدا لمحادثات بناء تعيد للبلد الوفي مع
شعبنا الاستقرار والسلام والتنميه كما
تؤكد الجمهوريه اليمنيه التزامها الكامل
بدعم حق الشعب الفلسطيني في اقامته
المستقله وعاصمه القدس الشريف الشرقيه
وفقا للمبادره السلام العربيه والقرارات
والتشريعات الدوليه
وتدين التصعيد الاسرائيلي المستمر
واجراءاته الاستيطانيه التي تقوض من فرص
السلام من فرص السلام والامن الاقليمي
والدولي اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
اصحاب المعالي والسعاده اسمحوا لي في
الختام ان اعرب عن خالص التمنياتي بالنجاح
لهذه القمه بقياده اخي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي
عهده صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان التي نثقوا بانها ستمثل نقله اضافيه
لمسار العرب العمل العربي المشترك وتوحيد
الياته في دعم جهود الاشقاء والاصدقاء
للسعاده مؤسسات الدوله اليمنيه وانهاء
الانقلاب والانتصارا لصبري وتضحيات شعبنا
وحقه في الحريه والكرامه الانسانيه والامن
والاستقرار والرخاء والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر فخامه الرئيس الدكتور رشاد العليمي
على كلمته ولا ندعو وسفير دفع الله الحاج
المبعوث الخاص للرئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني القاء كلمته فليتفضل
بسم الله والحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله
صاحب السمو الملكي ولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان رئيس مجلس الوزراء الساده اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسمو معالي السيد احمد
ابو الغيط الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه
السيدات والساده والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
تعالى وبركاته
اود في البدي التعبير عن تهانينا الصادقه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
لتسممها رئاسه هذه الدوره المهمه
ونثقوا انكم سمو الامير ستقودون اعمالها
نحو النجاح المنشود
كما نشكر جمهوريه الجزائر الديمقراطيه
الشعبيه الشقيقه على مبادلته من جهود
دؤوبه خلال رئاستها الاجتماعات القمه
السابقه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو اتشرف
بمخاطبتكم اليوم بتكليف من شقيقكم الفريق
والركنه عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقالي
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
والذي
يبلغكم تحياته وقد حاله
الظروف التي تعلمونها دون تواجده بينكم
اليوم
فهو الان بين قواته يقود معركه الكرامه
ضد قوات التمرد التي اطلقت رصاصه الغدر
والخيانه صبيحه يوم السبت الخامس عشر من
ابريل الماضي عندما هاجمت منزل سيادته
وعددا من المنشات العسكريه والمطارات بهدف
الاستيلاء على السلطه في الوقت الذي كانت
تمارس فيه الخداع
بالدعاء هازيفا انها تدعم التحول
الديمقراطي
وهو كان وما زال هو المطلب الاساسي لثوره
السودانيه
السيد الرئيس
تصدق قواتنا المسلحه ببساله للقوات
المتمرده وكان يمكنها حسم المعرفه في وقت
وجيز لولا ان تلك القوات التي يناهز عددها
الثمانين الف تسللت داخل الاحياء السكنيه
واتخذت من المؤسسات الخدميه والمستشفيات
والمنازل ثكنات عسكريه واحتجزت المدنيين
الابرياء العزل بمن فيهم كبار السن وذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه والنساء والاطفال دروعا
بشريه
ومارست اسوا انواع الدرائم من قتل ونهب
وسلب واغتصاب في انتهاك صارخ للقانون
الدولي الانساني
وانعانا في انتهاكاتها لم تلتزم حركه
التمرد بكل اتفاقات الهدنه وواصلت جرائمها
لتشمل البعثات الدبلوماسيه فاعتدد على
سفاره المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
والملحق الملحقيتين العسكريه والثقافيه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
وسفاره دوله الكويت وسفاره جمهوريه
الصومال الفيدراليه وقتلت مساعد نائب
الملحق الاداري بسفاره جمهوريه مصر
العربيه
واقتحمت وسلبت مقر المنظمه العربيه
للتنميه الزراعيه التابعه للجامعه العربيه
وعدد كبير من السفارات الاجنبيه الاخرى
وذلك في انتهاك سافر لاتفاقيه فيينا
للعلاقات الدبلوماسيه وفي ضوء ما اشرت
اليه من انتهاكات السيد الرئيس سمو الامير
يقلقنا غض المجتمع الدولي الطرف عن هذه
الانتهاكات التي تستوجب الشدب والادانه
والمساءله
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو ان حكومه
السودان استجعارا لمسؤوليتها تجاه
مواطنيها واحساسا
بمعاناتهم وما يتعرضون له من انتهاكات من
القوات المتمرده قبلت
مبادره الهدنه الانسانيه التي تقدمت بها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ونحن في السودان مطمئنون باننا سنتجاوز
هذه المحنه بوحدتنا وقوه ارادتنا
ومؤازرتكم
ومساندتكم المعهوده والتي تم تاكيدها في
القرار الذي اعتمدتموه اليوم حيث عبر عن
تضامنكم مع حكومه السودان وربط التدخل
الاجنبي في شؤون السودان الداخليه واكد ان
الازمه الحاليه شان داخلي
وامن على شرعيه الحكومه ومؤسسات الدوله
واحترام السياده الوطنيه والاستجابه لنداء
المساعدات الانسانيه السيد الرئيس نحن في
حكومه السودان
لسنا دعاه حرب لكنها فرضت علينا واذا ما
جنحت القوات المتمرده للسلم سنجنح
له واذا وضعوا السلاح سيتم العفو عنهم بل
وان ابواب القوه القوات المسلحه السودانيه
مشرعه لدمجهم ان رغبوا ولكن في ذات الوقت
اؤكد لكم ان القوات المسلحه السودانيه بما
عرف عنها عبر عقود من الزمان من كفاءه
واقدام وشجاعه ومهنيه عاليه
قادره على هزيمه التمرد فلا مجال للتشكيك
فيها كيف لا
كيف لا وجيشنا الوطني تربى على عقيده
حذاري ان وطنك يضام
وحذاري ان يصبح حطام وتربى على نحن في
الشده باس يتجلى ويعرفهم التاريخ فلا دور
ولا مجال للتشكيك فيها اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو تعلمون ان السودان في
اقليم كبير يضم 10 دول في جوار مباشر وغير
مباشر هو بمثابه صمام الامان وواسطه العقد
لهذا الاقليم ولكم من تتخيلوا اذا من فرط
هذا العقد لا قدر الله كيف ستكون تداعياته
على الاقليم باسره
لذلك نثق لكم ستقفون مع السودان لاحتواء
هذه الازمه وسترافقونه في المرحله القادمه
لاعاده التاهيل والاعمار لما احدثه التمرد
من دمار للبنا التحتيه والمؤسسات ختاما
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم
يستبشر السودان ببوادر السلام التي اخذت
تتبلور في المنطقه العربيه بعوده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وايران والتي تؤكد على حرص وسعي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لتحقيق الاستقرار والامن
في المنطقه ونحن نثمن دورها عاليا ونعلمه
تماما
كما يرحب السودان بعوده الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه الشقيقه للجامعه العربيه
ويثمن جهود لجنه الاتصال العربيه الوزاريه
في هذا الصدد وقد ظل السودان يدعو لعوده
سوريا الى بيت العرب وحرص على استمرار
علاقاته الدبلوماسيه معها اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو يؤكد السودان مجددا موقفه
الثابت من القضيه الفلسطينيه قضيه العربه
الاولى ويدين بشده الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه
الاخيره في الاراضي الفلسطينيه ويرحب
باتفاق اطلاق النار الذي تم التوصل اليه
مؤخرا بفضل جهود الوساطه المصريه
في الختام يود وابدا بلادي ان يعبر عن
فارغ الشكر والتقدير للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه على حفاوه الاستقبال
وكرم الضيافه والشكر والتقدير يمتد لمعالي
الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
والامانه العامه على حسن تنظيم فعاليات
هذه القمه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو امامكم
مشروع جدول الاعمال ومشاريع القرارات
واعلان جده فاذا لم يكن هناك اي ملاحظه
على ذلك اعلن اعتمادها
اعلن اعتماد قارات الصادره من قيمتكم
الموقره واعلان جده في الختام في ختام
اعمال القمه نتقدم بالشكر الجزيل لاصحاب
الجلال والفخامه لمشاركتهم وجهودهم مبذوله
لانجاح هذه القمه مع تمنياتنا بالتوفيق
والنجاح لمملكه البحرين الشقيقه في
استضافه القمه العربيه القادمه والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات